I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everybody. Hi there.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作《办公室》终极重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好。嗨。
We are back from our vacations and so excited to be back. So excited. The irony is that we recorded this before our vacations. So we have not actually vacationed yet, but in terms of it being released and your feed, here we are. Back from vacation. Yes. I don't know why that tickles me.
我们度假回来了，非常兴奋能回来。太兴奋了。讽刺的是，我们在度假前就录制了这一期。所以我们实际上还没去度假，但就发布和你们收听的时间而言，我们回来了。度假归来。是的。我不知道为什么这让我觉得很有趣。
We're time traveling right now. We are. In truth, we are recording on a Saturday because I got food poisoning last week. Yeah. But everyone came in. Hi, guys. Hi. Happy Saturday, everyone.
我们现在在进行时间旅行。确实。事实上，我们是在周六录制的，因为我上周食物中毒了。是的。但大家都来了。嗨，伙计们。嗨。大家周六快乐。
Happy Saturday to you as well. Today we are talking about Secretary's Day. It is season six, episode 22, written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Steve Carell. So exciting. That's a great duo. Would you like a summary? More than anything. All right.
也祝你周六快乐。今天我们要讨论的是“秘书节”。这是第六季第22集，由敏迪·卡灵编剧，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔执导。太令人兴奋了。这是一个很棒的组合。你想要剧情简介吗？再渴望不过了。好的。
Here it is. Andy tries to make Secretary's Day special for Erin. He encourages Michael to take Erin to lunch. Doing which, Michael accidentally reveals Andy's past engagement to Angela, something Erin did not know about. Meanwhile, a spoof video circulates likening Kevin to Cookie Monster, which Gabe finds offensive and he flexes his authority to squash it. I love that you called it a spoof video.
给你。安迪试图让秘书节对艾琳来说变得特别。他鼓励迈克尔带艾琳去吃午餐。在此过程中，迈克尔无意中透露了安迪过去与安吉拉的婚约，这是艾琳所不知道的。与此同时，一段将凯文比作饼干怪兽的恶搞视频流传开来，盖博觉得这很冒犯，于是他动用职权将其压制。我喜欢你称它为恶搞视频。
What would it be? Maybe like a parody video? Are they not the same? I think they are. I think they are. Maybe. It's just funny to me. Spoof video sounds funny to me.
那应该叫什么？也许叫模仿视频？它们不是一回事吗？我想是的。我想是的。也许吧。这对我来说很有趣。恶搞视频听起来很有趣。
Well I want to tell you all we do not have fast facts today. None. No fast facts. You want to know why? Why? I'll tell you. What is it? Ellie Kimber is our fast fact.
好吧，我要告诉大家，我们今天没有“快速事实”。一个都没有。没有快速事实。你想知道为什么吗？为什么？我告诉你。是什么？艾莉·坎伯就是我们的快速事实。
That's right. Yes, you guys. We spoke to Ellie earlier in the week. While Angela had food poisoning, by the way, you'll hear it in her voice. Ellie knew right away. Here's the thing. We had to do it over Zoom because I was, I had to be by a bathroom. Sorry, TMI.
没错。是的，伙计们。我们本周早些时候采访了艾莉。顺便说一下，当时安吉拉食物中毒了，你会从她的声音里听出来。艾莉立刻就发现了。事情是这样的，我们必须通过Zoom进行，因为我当时必须待在洗手间旁边。抱歉，信息量过大了。
And Ellie looked at me right away. I hadn't even said a word and she goes, are you okay? Yeah. But you guys, we were so excited to talk to Ellie and I didn't want to miss it. So here is our interview with Ellie. She's the best. Hi, Ellie. Hello, Ellie.
艾莉立刻看着我。我甚至还没说一句话，她就问，你还好吗？是的。但是伙计们，我们非常兴奋能和艾莉交谈，我不想错过。所以，这是我们对艾莉的采访。她是最好的。嗨，艾莉。你好，艾莉。
Hi, Jenna and Angela. How are you? Good. Welcome to Office Ladies. Welcome, welcome. Hello. I am so happy. To be here, I am a huge fan of your show, I'm a huge fan of the two of you and it is
嗨，珍娜和安吉拉。你们好吗？很好。欢迎来到《办公室女士》。欢迎，欢迎。你好。我太高兴了。能来到这里，我是你们节目的忠实粉丝，我是你们两位的忠实粉丝，而且
always delightful chatting with you. So thank you for having me. Ellie, you are a ray of sunshine that I can really use right now as Jenna knows. I have a little bit of food poisoning and I am, you're my first thing back from food poisoning. Okay. Congratulations. I hope I don't send you back, back into illness.
和你们聊天总是很愉快。所以谢谢你们邀请我。艾莉，你就像一缕阳光，正如珍娜所知，我现在真的很需要。我有点食物中毒，你是我就餐后恢复的第一件事。好的。恭喜。我希望我不会让你再次陷入疾病。
But I'm sorry that you're, I hope that you are feeling better, Angela. You are a trooper. I know you're not, you're not asking for compliments, but I'm here to tell you you're a trooper. So I'm glad that you're feeling a little better. I'll take them today. I'll take it. Well, Ellie, we always start our interviews with asking each person how they got their
但我很抱歉你，我希望你感觉好些了，安吉拉。你是个坚强的人。我知道你不是，你不是在寻求赞美，但我在这里告诉你，你是个坚强的人。所以我很高兴你感觉好了一些。我今天接受这些赞美。我接受。好吧，艾莉，我们总是以询问每个人是如何得到他们的
job on the office. I got my job on the office in sort of a roundabout way. I met with Greg Daniels and Mike Schur, like, you know, at the beginning of 2008, maybe when they were developing Parks and Recreation. And I believe, although I was never explicitly told that I was auditioning for Parks and Recreation, like there was an untitled script that I read from in a room with Greg and Allison Jones. Nothing ever came of it. The characters didn't have any names that matched the ones on what was to become Parks
在《办公室》的工作开始我们的采访。我得到《办公室》的工作方式有点迂回。我在2008年初，也就是他们开发《公园与游憩》的时候，见到了格雷格·丹尼尔斯和迈克·舒尔。我相信，虽然我从未被明确告知我是在为《公园与游憩》试镜，但我确实在和格雷格及艾莉森·琼斯的一个房间里读过一份无标题的剧本。后来什么也没发生。角色没有任何名字与后来成为《公园与游憩》的角色相符。
and Recreation. I really don't know what I was doing in that room with them, but that's how I met them. Then later that, you know, like a few months later, there was an audition when Pam went to go work at the Michael Scott paper company. There was an opening for a temporary secretary. And so since I had already met some of those, you know, big guys from the office, it was two guys. That's why I said big guys.
我真的不知道我在那个房间里和他们一起做什么，但那就是我见到他们的方式。后来，你知道，几个月后，当帕姆去迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司工作时，有一次试镜。有一个临时秘书的空缺。所以因为我已经见过那些，你知道，来自《办公室》的大人物了，那是两个家伙。这就是为什么我说大人物。
I was, I guess, on their, in their world, in their orbit. So I came in to read for that part, I read with Ed Helms. And then I got the call, you know, the next week that I had booked the part. So that's how I got on the office, you guys. Wow. That is so wow. You know what though? I remember like showrunners would do that if they had a project, they didn't want it
我想我当时在他们的世界里，在他们的轨道上。所以我进来读那个角色，我和艾德·赫尔姆斯一起读。然后我接到了电话，你知道，下周我就拿到了那个角色。所以这就是我进入《办公室》的方式，伙计们。哇。那真是太哇了。不过你知道吗？我记得剧集主管如果有一个项目，他们不想让它
leaked out in any way. You would go in sometimes and read and not really know much about what you were reading for. Right. And that's kind of how you met Greg. You were, I'm sure that was Parks and Rec. You know, it sounds like it. It had to have been, I don't know what part it was, like I never, they wanted to keep
以任何方式泄露。你有时会进去读剧本，却不知道自己在读什么。对。这就是你见到格雷格的方式。我敢肯定那是《公园与游憩》。你知道，听起来是这样。一定是，我不知道那是什么部分，就像我从来没有，他们想保持
everything a little tight-lipped. But, but yeah, I mean, you guys, it goes without saying. So that was, that was the end of season five, I think that I came on. I was such a fan of the office. So it's like, I mean, I watched it with my family. I watched it, you know, by myself. It was surreal actually meeting you guys for the first time because I was so familiar with the show and felt like I already knew you.
一切都守口如瓶。但是，但是是的，我的意思是，伙计们，不用说。所以那是，那是第五季的结尾，我想我加入了。我是《办公室》的忠实粉丝。所以，我的意思是，我和家人一起看。我，你知道，自己看。第一次见到你们真的很不真实，因为我对这部剧太熟悉了，感觉好像已经认识你们了。
You played it so cool. Oh, Ellie. I know. I would have never known. You were super like, Hey, what's up? You weren't, you didn't go crazy. Oh, well, that is my finest performance because I was like, my heart inside was just like beating a million miles a minute with a sitcom.
你表现得太冷静了。哦，艾莉。我知道。我永远不会知道。你超级像，嘿，怎么了？你没有，你没有发疯。哦，好吧，那是我的最佳表演，因为我当时，我的内心就像每分钟跳动一百万英里一样，带着情景喜剧。
They're in your living room every week. You feel like you know them. I'm sure this happens to you all the time where people feel like they know you very well, even though you've never met them. And so I felt like I knew all of you and yet you had never seen my face before. So it's a surreal experience of suddenly working alongside these people who you sort of consider to be your friends, but also icons. And so it was all of that at once and it was, it was a lot.
他们每周都在你的客厅里。你觉得你认识他们。我相信这总是发生在你身上，人们觉得他们非常了解你，即使你从未见过他们。所以我感觉我认识你们所有人，但你们以前从未见过我的脸。所以这是一种超现实的体验，突然与这些人一起工作，你把他们视为你的朋友，但也视为偶像。所以这一切同时发生，这，这很多。
So I'm really glad you thought I played it cool because I didn't feel cool. Now originally it was just supposed to be a few episodes, right? And then Pam was going to come back from Michael Scott paper company. And I remembered discussions about whether or not Pam would return to the receptionist desk or do something else. And I had sat down with Greg and he asked me my opinion. He said, what do you think Pam would want? And I said, well, I don't know after art school and this big move with Michael, I feel like
所以我很高兴你认为我表现得很冷静，因为我感觉不冷静。现在最初它应该只是几集，对吧？然后帕姆要从迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司回来。我记得关于帕姆是否会回到接待处还是做其他事情的讨论。我曾和格雷格坐下来，他问我的意见。他说，你觉得帕姆会想要什么？我说，嗯，我不知道在艺术学校和迈克尔的这次大变动之后，我觉得
it might be a little depressing if she's just back at reception again. I would love some movement for this woman. And he agreed and he said, all right, I think we're going to make Pam part of the sales team and we're going to move her to the desk clump with Dwight and Jim. And then that kind of opened the door for we need someone to sit at reception. And Ellie, you were so beloved by everyone. I mean, listen, there is a chance that Greg was making me feel like I had a part of that decision.
如果她只是回到接待处，可能会有点令人沮丧。我很乐意为这个女人做一些变动。他同意了，他说，好吧，我想我们要让帕姆成为销售团队的一员，我们要把她调到和德怀特及吉姆一起的办公桌群。然后这为我们需要有人坐在接待处打开了大门。艾莉，你深受大家的喜爱。我的意思是，听着，格雷格有可能让我觉得我在那个决定中有一份功劳。
But the real story was, listen, we're not letting Ellie Kemper go. So we're going to make you feel good by telling you Pam to move to sales. But OK, because everyone was so excited for you to come on in a more permanent position. What was that part like for your end? OK, Jenna, first of all, I have to say first and foremost, thank you for your input that Pam should be promoted to salesperson because you gave me in real life a job with a paycheck on one of the most iconic shows in television history. So thank you.
但真实的故事是，听着，我们不会让艾莉·坎伯走。所以我们要通过告诉你要把帕姆调到销售部来让你感觉良好。但是好吧，因为每个人都非常兴奋你能以更永久的职位加入。这对你来说是什么样的？好的，珍娜，首先，我必须首先说，谢谢你的建议，帕姆应该被提升为销售员，因为你在现实生活中给了我一份工作，在电视史上最具标志性的节目之一上有一份薪水。所以谢谢。
I did not give you gave yourself a job by kicking ass in that role. That's right. You won that job. You won the over in the room, Ellie. You really did. And then you showed up and you crushed it. So you're the reason you were there 100 percent. Yeah.
我没有给你，是你自己通过在那个角色中表现出色而赢得了一份工作。没错。你赢得了那份工作。你在房间里赢得了胜利，艾莉。你真的做到了。然后你出现了，你表现得非常出色。所以你是你在那里的原因，百分之百。是的。
Everyone is I just more. I need you. I need to listen to you when I wake up every morning, like you need to be in my bathroom me or say, God, you can do it. You can do it. So thank you for those very, very encouraging words. What was that moment when they called you and they said, we're going to make this character a regular character?
每个人都是我只是更多。我需要你。我每天早上醒来都需要听你的声音，就像你需要在我洗手间的镜子里，或者说，天哪，你能做到。你能做到。所以谢谢你那些非常，非常鼓励的话。当他们打电话给你，说我们要让这个角色成为常驻角色时，那一刻是什么样的？
That was insane. Oh, yes. I think the arc was at first four episodes and maybe six. But then it, you know, Aaron stayed for the rest of the season and then it wasn't until June. So the show had stopped. I guess the show and that season ended in May. And in June is when they called my agents and then my agents called me to say that we
那太疯狂了。哦，是的。我想最初的弧线是四集，也许六集。但后来，你知道，艾琳留下了剩下的赛季，然后直到六月。所以节目停止了。我想节目和那个赛季在五月结束了。而在六月，他们打电话给我的经纪人，然后我的经纪人打电话给我说我们
want to offer her a, you know, a regular spot on the show. And that that is like you have won the lottery, of course, because and which I do feel that I did because not only creatively is the show just so spectacular, but I just felt so lucky to be working with normal people who didn't have, there were no egos. There was, I mean, you were there longer than I was, but I, there was no like fighting or like drama. It felt like a very, very nice group of people to work with and it was. So I felt again, like, okay, this is, wow, this is my big break.
想给她一个，你知道，节目中的常驻位置。而那就像你中了彩票，当然，因为，我也觉得我做到了，因为不仅在创意上这部剧非常壮观，而且我感到非常幸运能与没有，没有自我的人一起工作。我的意思是，你在那里比我久，但我，没有像争吵或像戏剧。感觉像是一个非常，非常好的群体一起工作，确实如此。所以我再次觉得，好吧，这是，哇，这是我的重大突破。
And so that, that was an exhilarating moment when I got that call. Our writer, Jean told us that for your first episode, and this is so crazy, Ellie, that you were asked to perform the role of Aaron two ways in every scene because they were still trying to figure out exactly what they needed from your character. And so the one way we know her as right is just so adorable and she just desperately wants Michael to love her and like her and it's so cute. But I guess the other way was like a sarcastic version. Do you remember this?
所以那，那是当我接到那个电话时令人振奋的时刻。我们的编剧吉恩告诉我们，对于你的第一集，这太疯狂了，艾莉，你被要求在每个场景中以两种方式表演艾琳的角色，因为他们还在试图弄清楚他们到底需要你的角色做什么。所以我们认识她的方式是如此可爱，她只是拼命想要迈克尔爱她和喜欢她，这太可爱了。但我猜另一种方式是像讽刺版本。你还记得吗？
I do remember that and I'm glad you brought that up because I do remember that specific direction, which was we haven't really figured this character out yet. And so there were, I don't know if it was every take, but there were moments where it was, okay, they were just sort of, you know, I think adjusting and like modulating the character in terms of what she would be. And so there were a lot of takes where it was just more straightforward and a little bit, you know, I guess, I don't want to say cynical, but just a little bit more serious, I think, but that's not the direction Aaron ended up going.
我记得，我很高兴你提到了这一点，因为我确实记得那个具体的指导，那就是我们还没有真正弄清楚这个角色。所以有，我不知道是不是每个镜头，但有时刻是，好吧，他们只是某种，你知道，我想调整和像调节角色，就她会是什么而言。所以有很多镜头只是更直接，有点，你知道，我想，我不想说愤世嫉俗，但只是稍微更严肃一点，我想，但那不是艾琳最终发展的方向。
But that's very interesting to be there, you know, at the introduction of a new character as and to see like how, you know, the writers and director and actors sort of figured out this new person in the office. Do you remember when they told you, okay, we figured it out. We've picked an Aaron. Yeah, no, I think it was more, I think it was more gradual and honestly, it's like, I don't know if it was just from talking with them in real life because I do, I did you guys ever experience this where you'd be like talking with a right with Midi or BJ at the
但作为一个新角色的介绍，在那里，你知道，看到像，你知道，编剧和导演和演员是如何，某种程度上弄清楚这个办公室里的新人的，这非常有趣。你还记得他们什么时候告诉你，好吧，我们弄清楚了。我们选定了一个艾琳。是的，不，我想这更多，我想这更渐进，老实说，就像，我不知道这是否只是因为在现实生活中和他们交谈，因为我确实，我做过你们曾经经历过这个吗，你会像和编剧，和敏迪或BJ在
crafty and then all of a sudden you're like, wait a second, it's not exactly something you said, but something sort of related to what you said made its way into a script. I'm not taking credit for writing. I'm just saying that I think certain parts of my personality may have been incorporated into the aspects of Aaron. We're here to like, um, Oh, Emily, we talk about this all the time. We totally say that one of the things we became aware of is having writers on the set, which
手工制作室交谈，然后突然你就像，等一下，这不完全是你说的，但与你说的相关的东西进入了剧本。我不是在为写作邀功。我只是说我认为我个性的某些部分可能被纳入了艾琳的方面。我们在这里像，嗯，哦，艾莉，我们一直在谈论这个。我们完全说我们意识到的事情之一是在片场有编剧，这
is pretty unique and having them as cast members, that they were sort of always paying attention and little moments of our real lives or things would end up in scripts very subtly, but they'd be there. Right, right. And so, so then I'm like, oh, to be fly on the wall, that writer's room, like, what are they picking up? But also like checking what I say, I think I learned the lesson, not that it's a lesson, but I think I picked up on that too late where I was like, Oh, right, they're, they're everything's
是相当独特的，让他们作为演员，他们某种程度上总是注意，我们真实生活中的小瞬间或事情会非常微妙地出现在剧本中，但它们会在那里。对，对。所以，所以然后我就像，哦，成为墙上的苍蝇，那个编剧室，像，他们在捡起什么？但也像检查我说的话，我想我学到了教训，不是说这是一个教训，但我认为我太晚才意识到这一点，当时我就像，哦，对，他们，他们一切都是
material or everything's copy, whatever that quote is, but anyway, yeah. And I love, love how different her relationship with Michael is than Pam's relationship. And I thought that was really important. She brought out this whole other side of him and I, I loved it. I always thought of it as a father-daughter relationship and, you know, Aaron didn't have a dad, a stable father, paternal figure growing up and, you know, Michael, they have quirks that are similar, I think, and so they mesh, but yeah, Pam, like, I don't know if it's a wisdom or just like a, a ability to perceive that's a little sharper than Aaron's,
素材或一切都是文案，无论那句名言是什么，但无论如何，是的。而且我喜欢，喜欢她与迈克尔的关系与帕姆的关系有多么不同。我觉得这真的很重要。她带出了他完全不同的一面，我，我喜欢它。我一直认为这是一种父女关系，而且，你知道，艾琳成长过程中没有爸爸，一个稳定的父亲，父性形象，而且，你知道，迈克尔，他们有相似的怪癖，我想，所以他们很合拍，但是是的，帕姆，像，我不知道这是一种智慧还是只是像一种，一种感知能力，比艾琳的稍微敏锐一点，
but that was not the relationship you had with Michael. I mean, Pam had with Michael. I think maybe Pam had a kind of mother-son relationship with Michael. Pam was a bit of like a surrogate caretaker. Yeah. More of a nurturer, try to steer him, steer him exactly that's exactly what I was looking for. Yep.
但那不是你与迈克尔的关系。我的意思是，帕姆与迈克尔的关系。我想也许帕姆与迈克尔有一种母子关系。帕姆有点像代理看护人。是的。更多的是一个培育者，试图引导他，引导他，这正是我想找的。是的。
That's exactly right. Um, well, I love your romance with Andy. I have been really enjoying that part of this rewatch and I feel like that was one of the first things that really brought your character more to the forefront. And now here, secretary's day, big A story, I mean, what was that like, Andrew and I know what it's like to have a little bit more of a supporting role on the show. And then all of a sudden you get thrust into one of these big storylines and you suddenly have all these scenes with Steve Carell, who is also directing like it was, that was crazy.
那完全正确。嗯，我喜欢你和安迪的浪漫。我真的很享受这次重温的那部分，我觉得那是第一件真正让你的角色更突出的事情。现在在这里，秘书节，大的A故事，我的意思是，那是什么样的，安德鲁和我知道在节目中扮演稍微多一点的支持角色是什么感觉。然后突然你被推入这些大的故事情节之一，你突然有了所有这些与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的场景，他也是导演，就像它是，那太疯狂了。
And I didn't have any warning or anything like it wasn't until sitting down at the table read, right? What? Yes. You just, you sat down at the table read, opened your script and you're reading it cold and you're like, oh my gosh, or maybe you read it in your trailer 30 minutes before, but still, that is my experience of like every script we got. Like that's how I found out.
而且我没有任何警告或任何东西，就像直到坐在剧本朗读会上，对吧？什么？是的。你只是，你坐在剧本朗读会上，打开你的剧本，你冷读它，你就像，哦，天哪，或者也许你在30分钟前在你的拖车里读过它，但仍然，那是我的经历，像我们得到的每个剧本。就像那是我是怎么发现的。
Right. Angela was going to hook up with Dwight. Right. What? Right. 30 minutes. I mean, because Mindy broke that episode, as we all know, and maybe there had been, maybe she had been saying, I can't remember.
对。安吉拉要和德怀特勾搭上。对。什么？对。30分钟。我的意思是，因为敏迪打破了那一集，正如我们所知，也许曾经有过，也许她一直在说，我不记得了。
I remember that having a discussion with her where she was like, oh, it'd be, it'd be fun. I can't remember if it was about secretary's day, but it was something she was writing and she had some idea for Aaron. So maybe there was an inkling of that, but certainly not the A story, which is such a thrill. And like you said, it was probably 30 minutes before the table read in your trailer and you're like, oh my gosh, and then, and then like, and, and like very seriously for Aaron, who did have, you know, a very supportive role, that's to say, like a few lines every episode
我记得和她有过讨论，她就像，哦，那会，那会很有趣。我不记得是不是关于秘书节，但那是她正在写的东西，她对艾琳有一些想法。所以也许有一点那种暗示，但肯定不是A故事，这真是太令人兴奋了。而且就像你说的，那可能是在剧本朗读会前30分钟在你的拖车里，你就像，哦，天哪，然后，然后像，而且，而且像非常认真地对待艾琳，她确实有，你知道，一个非常支持的角色，也就是说，每集几句台词
that suddenly you're saying all these things and you're into all these important scenes and it feels, it felt really, really cool. And not that there was anyone who wasn't, you know, great writer or director on the show, but I really loved that Mindy had written it and that Steve was going to direct it because like, you know, it's, he's, he, he, he's so beloved. And then to know that he was going to be directing this episode, it just all felt very special to me. Yeah.
突然你说了所有这些事情，你进入了所有这些重要的场景，它感觉，它感觉真的，真的很酷。并不是说节目中没有谁不是，你知道，伟大的编剧或导演，但我真的很喜欢敏迪写了它，史蒂夫要导演它，因为就像，你知道，它是，他，他，他如此受人喜爱。然后知道他要导演这一集，这一切对我来说都感觉非常特别。是的。
And you and Mindy were, you know, you guys were friends on set, you would hang out and so all of a sudden she's there too. And that must have been a great feeling that you had two people that you knew and trusted and worked with a lot up until this point. That's exactly right. So it felt very, I like, I used the word safe and felt just like there was a lot of security there because I did know both of them. I loved your driving scenes.
而且你和敏迪是，你知道，你们在片场是朋友，你们会一起出去玩，所以突然她也在那里。那一定是一种伟大的感觉，你有两个你认识和信任的人，并且到目前为止一起工作了很多。那完全正确。所以它感觉非常，我喜欢，我用了“安全”这个词，感觉就像那里有很多安全感，因为我确实认识他们两个。我喜欢你的驾驶场景。
I loved that Erin looked up conversation topics and she was just going to throw them all out, everything she had. And there's even more in the deleted scenes, you know, I'm going to share them in the episode, but you look like you were having a lot of fun. Lady, that was like, again, it feels like something that you offer as a prize at an auction. You're like, oh, you can, I mean, I know that I do this professionally, but it's still felt like, you know, something that, oh, you get to, so the prize is you get to ride in
我喜欢艾琳查找谈话话题，她只是要抛出它们，她拥有的一切。而且删除的场景里还有更多，你知道，我会在这一集里分享它们，但你看起来玩得很开心。女士，那就像，再次，感觉就像你作为拍卖奖品提供的东西。你就像，哦，你可以，我的意思是，我知道我专业地做这个，但它仍然感觉像，你知道，某种东西，哦，你得到，所以奖品是你得到乘坐
a car with Steve Porral. You're acting. He's also directing it. And then you get to say these like really crazy absurd and funny things to him and like, you know, and there were just, as I recall, there were a lot of just like, you know, alts and, you know, and just we kept doing those in the restaurant and in the car and like, I think there had been one driving scene with Michael Scott before that on for Scott's Tots.
一辆有史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的车。你在演戏。他也在导演它。然后你得到对他说这些像非常疯狂荒谬和有趣的事情，像，你知道，而且正如我所记得的，有很多只是像，你知道，备选方案和，你知道，而且只是我们在餐厅和车里一直这样做，而且，我想在那之前迈克尔·斯科特有过一个驾驶场景，关于斯科特的托特。
And that was, I think that was the other time I had been driving with him, but yeah, they're such a funny pair. It's fun to see those two characters together. There were a few moments where Steve is Michael just as exasperated on how to connect with Aaron. And it's, it's like so painful for him. And it was so funny to watch him do those scenes because we don't really see Michael like that.
而那，我想那是另一次我和他一起开车，但是是的，他们是一对如此有趣的一对。看到那两个角色在一起很有趣。有几个时刻，史蒂夫作为迈克尔同样对如何与艾琳建立联系感到恼火。而且它，它对他来说太痛苦了。而且看他做那些场景太有趣了，因为我们真的没见过那样的迈克尔。
It's constantly once everyone else's attention and approval. So to see him not wanting someone's attention is really funny. It's so, it's like, I was seeing the exact same thing. I just rewatched it and seeing him be exasperated. You never see that. He's always the one exasperating others. And so for him to be out, you know, annoyed, and I'm not sure that's the right word, but is really rare and hilarious.
它不断地想要其他人的注意和认可。所以看到他不想要某人的注意真的很有趣。它太，就像，我看到了完全一样的事情。我刚刚重温了它，看到他感到恼火。你从来没见过。他总是那个让别人恼火的人。所以对他来说，你知道，烦恼，我不确定那是不是正确的词，但确实非常罕见且滑稽。
Ellie, we got this fan question. It's not even really a question. Part of a comment, Reagan H. from Boston, Massachusetts wrote in to say, shout out to Ellie Kemper for this episode, because every single line that she delivers in the restaurant scene is Emmy worthy, Emmy worthy. She loves your performance. I have to agree. I agree.
艾莉，我们收到了这个粉丝问题。这甚至不是一个真正的问题。评论的一部分，来自马萨诸塞州波士顿的里根·H写道，向艾莉·坎伯致敬，因为她在餐厅场景中交付的每一句台词都值得艾美奖，值得艾美奖。她喜欢你的表演。我必须同意。我同意安吉拉。
Excuse me again, bring Reagan into the bathroom mirror. I don't know how I'm going to set this up guys. I want to look in the bathroom mirror and have your faces coming out and saying encouraging things to me. I think you're on to like some kind of app. I think I am. I think you are too. I think you should sell this.
再次抱歉，把里根带进洗手间的镜子里。我不知道我该怎么设置这个，伙计们。我想看洗手间的镜子，让你们的脸出来，对我说鼓励的话。我想你正在开发某种应用程序。我想我是。我想你也是。我想你应该卖掉这个。
It's going to be something that projects up there and they're just holograms coming. I'm working on it. I'm working on it. That's incredible. Those lines were written by Mindy and it's easy to deliver lines that, as we all know, that are written so brilliantly. And they were just like, I think there were a couple of times when Steve was like, okay, and then, you know, because we all know there was room for improv.
它将是某种投射在那里的东西，它们只是全息图正在过来。我正在努力。我正在努力。那太不可思议了。那些台词是敏迪写的，交付那些台词很容易，正如我们所知，写得如此出色。而且它们只是像，我想有几次史蒂夫就像，好的，然后，你知道，因为我们都知道有即兴表演的空间。
I found that to be so scary, like doing a run or whatever, because I think there's so much pressure on, and there were, there were a few. I don't think any made it into the show, but I remember, I was like, I don't want to have, I don't want to do that during the table scene, but it's like, it's like the, it was such an opportunity for Aaron. And then it was just like every line that was written was, was so pitch perfect. So, so thanks for sharing that, Jenna, but half of the work was, you know, in the, in the writing.
我发现那太可怕了，像做一轮或什么的，因为我认为压力太大了，而且有，有几个。我不认为任何一个进入了节目，但我记得，我当时想，我不想有，我不想在桌子场景中那样做，但它就像，它就像艾琳的一个机会。然后它只是像每一句写的台词都是，是如此完美。所以，所以谢谢你的分享，珍娜，但一半的工作是，你知道，在，在写作中。
Well, my other favorite scene is in the conference room after you throw cake and Andy's face, and it hits him with like a flap. Like it is such a, I couldn't have hit him better. Like, his eyes are completely covered. Terrific aim. Thank you. Thank you.
嗯，我另一个最喜欢的场景是在会议室，在你把蛋糕扔在安迪脸上之后，它像一个襟翼一样击中他。就像它，我不可能击中得更好。就像，他的眼睛完全被覆盖了。极好的瞄准。谢谢。谢谢。
Really well done. But then you have this breakdown. I just, and the emotion underneath it, and what's so great about it is just how you really grounded it in some real emotion and real hurt. It was never just like sort of like an over the top comedic take on it. It was, it was so, oh, it just really broke my heart for your character. I love that scene. Yeah.
真的做得很好。但随后你有了这次崩溃。我只是，而且下面的情感，而且关于它最棒的是你如何真正地把它建立在一些真实的情感和真实的伤害中。它从来不只是像某种像一个过度的喜剧表演。它，它太，哦，它真的为你的角色伤了我的心。我喜欢那个场景。是的。
Well, thank you for saying that I, I remember, I, I do have vivid memories of that day and episode because it is the first time Aaron really has an emotional moments and a full on, like you said, breakdown. And I was very nervous about that because not only from an acting point of view, which was just, okay, you need to find these feelings in there and need to dig deep on this day. But also I was really intimidated to do it in front of all of you guys. Because I did, again, there's always that element of like, I joined halfway and like everyone is, I just did not want to derail any train.
嗯，谢谢你这么说，我，我记得，我，我确实对那天和那一集有生动的记忆，因为这是艾琳第一次真正有情感时刻和完全的，像你说的，崩溃。而且我对此非常紧张，因为不仅从表演的角度来看，这只是，好的，你需要找到那里的这些感觉，并且需要在这一天深入挖掘。而且我也非常害怕在你们所有人面前做这件事。因为我确实，再次，总是有那种像，我中途加入，而且像每个人都是，我只是不想让任何火车脱轨。
So I was like, okay, this is going to be, you know, the first time doing this in front of this group of people, something more serious. And so I just was very, very anxious that day. But I do remember making the target of his face and feeling like, okay, good, we're not going to have to clean up the cake and do it again. That would have been, I would have been stressed about that. Did you only hit him with cake one time? I feel like yes.
所以我当时想，好的，这将是，你知道，第一次在这一群人面前做这个，更严肃的事情。所以我那天非常，非常焦虑。但我确实记得瞄准他的脸，感觉像，好的，很好，我们不必清理蛋糕再做一次。那将是，我会为此感到压力。你只用蛋糕击中他一次吗？我觉得是的。
I want to say yes. Amazing. I don't want to brag and I don't want to rewrite history. That may not have been the case, but I just remember feeling happy that it didn't go on the wall. Like there wasn't a massive cleanup and I remember there wasn't. When I watched that scene, everyone's reaction seems so genuine that I feel like it was the first take because we're all like, oh, I feel like there's two things happening.
我想说是的。太棒了。我不想吹牛，我也不想重写历史。那可能不是那样，但我只是记得很高兴它没有掉在墙上。就像没有大规模的清理，而且我记得没有。当我观看那个场景时，每个人的反应看起来都如此真实，以至于我觉得那是第一次拍摄，因为我们都像，哦，我觉得有两件事正在发生。
One, as actors were reacting to this moment, but then as just humans were like, Ellie nailed him. I agree with Angela. That is definitely our real reaction to the cake hitting his face in that scene. And I could not have faked that reaction. That was your phenomenal actions. You could have, you could have rewatched the scene for the reactions. It's just us.
第一，作为演员，我们正在对这一刻做出反应，但随后作为人类，我们就像，艾莉击中了他。我同意安吉拉。那绝对是我们对蛋糕击中他脸的真实反应。而且我不可能伪造那种反应。那是你非凡的动作。你可以，你可以重温那个场景看反应。那只是我们。
I'm going to rewatch. I was going to say, I was so excited because Angela and Aaron got to have a scene together, which rarely happened. I know. And I mean, at front reception, sitting over there in these hushed tones and I remember that we had that scene, but Ellie, I had forgotten the dialogue, you know, like I knew I was basically saying to you, don't, you don't need to be worried, right? And then when I watched it and I was like, you're throwing up for the wrong reasons.
我要重温。我本来想说，我太兴奋了，因为安吉拉和艾琳终于有了一个场景，这很少发生。我知道。而且我的意思是，在接待处，坐在那边用这些低沉的语调，我记得我们有那个场景，但是艾莉，我忘记了对话，你知道，就像我知道我基本上是在对你说，不要，你不需要担心，对吧？然后当我观看它时，我当时想，你因为错误的原因呕吐。
And our dialogue was so ridiculous, but the sentiment was so real and that's exactly right. And then to see that Toby had been there the whole time, it's just like, it's so funny. And it's also, and in my memory of it before rewatching it, I, I thought it was longer and had more substance like that though is, is, is inconsequential, but that is like, it was quick and it's mostly about throw up. Yeah. So it's like, yeah, so, so it's like, I thought for some reason it was more of a heart to
而且我们的对话太荒谬了，但情感是如此真实，这完全正确。然后看到托比一直都在那里，这只是像，太有趣了。而且它也是，而且在我重温它之前的记忆中，我，我以为它更长，有更多实质内容，像那样，是，是，是不重要的，但那就像，它很快，而且主要是关于呕吐。是的。所以它就像，是的，所以，所以它就像，我出于某种原因以为它更多的是心对
heart, but it wasn't. No. And that's really a funny lie. Throwing up for the wrong reason. Yeah. Well, Pam tries to have a heart to heart with Aaron and it was really good. I thought what Pam said was so good. And I thought, oh, maybe this is sinking in.
心，但它不是。不。而且那真的是一句有趣的谎言。因为错误的原因呕吐。是的。嗯，帕姆试图与艾琳进行心对心的交流，这真的很好。我觉得帕姆说的话太好了。而且我想，哦，也许这正在沉入。
I thought so too. No. Well, Ellie, another question we always ask our guests is if they took anything from set when the show was over. Yeah. What'd you take? I took something that I feel confident I was not supposed to take. It's in my closet.
我也这么想。不。嗯，艾莉，我们总是问客人的另一个问题是，当节目结束时，他们是否从片场拿走了什么。是的。你拿了什么？我拿了一些我觉得我有信心我不应该拿的东西。它在我的衣柜里。
So I'm not going to show. Okay. It's, I don't, I mean, not that anyone could see it, but you'll know immediately where I'm trying to out. It's in Michael Scott's office. It's music is the friendship of life. Wow. Friendship is the music of life is that bulletin board, you guys, with all of the photos in
所以我不会展示。好的。它，我不，我的意思是，并不是任何人都能看到它，但你会立即知道我在哪里试图出去。它在迈克尔·斯科特的办公室里。它的音乐是生活的友谊。哇。友谊是生活的音乐，是那个公告栏，你们，所有照片在
a music night. Stop it. Yeah. I have that. Oh my gosh. You got to hold it up. You got to hold it up. That is so amazing.
一个音乐之夜。停下。是的。我有那个。哦，天哪。你得把它举起来。你得把它举起来。那太神奇了。
That is so cool. I mean, how did I get this? Did you just grab it off the wall and like leave after we wrapped? I must have. And how cool is it? It's got all the pictures of the cast and everything. Ellie, did you take anything else? I took Aaron's.
那太酷了。我的意思是，我是怎么得到这个的？你只是把它从墙上抓下来，像我们在包装后离开？我一定是。而且它有多酷？它有所有演员的照片和一切。艾莉，你还拿了别的吗？我拿了艾琳的。
It was like a ski. I really hope this wasn't Pam's. The ski boot. The ski boot. The ski boot. We loved it. You took the ski boot. Yes.
它就像一个滑雪。我真的希望这不是帕姆的。滑雪靴。滑雪靴。滑雪靴。我们喜欢它。你拿了滑雪靴。是的。
Okay. Good. I took it, but you're going to be there. That was Aaron's. That wasn't Pam's. That was never on Pam's desk. Yes. We noted that.
好的。很好。我拿了它，但你会去那里。那是艾琳的。那不是帕姆的。那从来不在帕姆的桌子上。是的。我们注意到了。
Oh, there was also a little bear. Yeah. And we were like, is Aaron a ski enthusiast and we didn't know it? I never. Was that question ever answered? No. I don't think it was ever brought up. We're going to continue to rewatch and we were curious if you ever were revealed as
哦，还有一个小熊。是的。而且我们就像，艾琳是滑雪爱好者吗，我们不知道？我从来没有。那个问题曾经被回答过吗？不。我不认为它曾经被提出来过。我们将继续重温，我们很好奇你是否曾经被揭示为
a skier. I don't. I want to say no, but I mean, maybe we'll, you know, uncover something that none of us remembers. I'm glad we all have a little piece of the show is such a big part of our lives. Well, let's see. Is there anything else? Like Ellie, is there any sort of favorite memory you have from this episode or anything
一个滑雪者。我不。我想说不，但我的意思是，也许我们会，你知道，发现一些我们都不记得的东西。我很高兴我们都有节目的一小部分，这是我们生活中如此重要的一部分。嗯，让我们看看。还有别的吗？像艾莉，你对这一集有什么最喜欢的记忆，或者任何
that you wanted to share behind the scenes moment or anything like that? I was just going to say my favorite part of this episode is the end. I felt like that when Michael is trying to cheer Aaron up on the bench outside and it's a really, really tender moment. I thought where it is this dad saying like, you can do better. And I mean, I've had those moments in real life where my dad is, you know, like I'm getting over a breakup or whatever. And my dad who's, you know, not normally emotional like that would try to help me feel better.
你想要分享的幕后时刻或类似的东西吗？我只是想说这一集我最喜欢的部分是结尾。我觉得当迈克尔试图在长椅外让艾琳振作起来时，这是一个非常，非常温柔的时刻。我想在哪里是这个爸爸说像，你可以做得更好。而且我的意思是，我在现实生活中也有过那些时刻，我的爸爸是，你知道，像我正在克服分手或什么的。而且我的爸爸，你知道，通常不像那样情绪化，会试图帮助我感觉更好。
And that's what this felt like with Michael and Aaron. And it was just a great moment because, you know, we were shooting it and it was a scene between the two of us and it just felt like Steve Carell is also saying it's going to be okay. It felt like a part of the cast in real life. And it felt like I'm in the fabric of the show now and it just felt very special. So to be able to do that, of course, is something that I'll remember forever. And it was, I just, I remember that as being my favorite moment from that episode to answer
而这就是迈克尔和艾琳的感觉。而且这是一个伟大的时刻，因为，你知道，我们正在拍摄它，这是我们两人之间的场景，它只是感觉史蒂夫·卡瑞尔也在说一切都会好起来的。它感觉像现实生活中演员的一部分。而且它感觉我现在在节目的结构中，它只是感觉非常特别。所以能够做到这一点，当然，是我永远会记得的事情。而且它，我只是，我记得那是那一集中我最喜欢的时刻，回答
the question. I love that. You know, what's such a sweet way to end the episode? I know. Yeah. I love those moments when Michael gets the opportunity to rise to the occasion and, and he does. I know.
这个问题。我喜欢那个。你知道，以如此甜蜜的方式结束这一集是什么？我知道。是的。我喜欢那些迈克尔有机会挺身而出的时刻，而且，而且他做到了。我知道。
And that was one of those moments. Yep. I, I loved that scene between the two of you. I loved it. And I remember talking to Greg at the end of the series and, and just talking about the show as a whole. And the thing is that like, it's such a funny, funny show. Like that's why I started watching it with my family.
而那是那些时刻之一。是的。我，我喜欢你们两人之间的那个场景。我喜欢它。而且我记得在系列结束时与格雷格交谈，而且，而且只是谈论整个节目。而事情是，就像，它是一部如此有趣，有趣的节目。就像那就是为什么我开始和我的家人一起看它。
Like it's, it's immediately relatable and really funny show, but it's so rare because it has such a heart, you know, at the center, but I know it's all been said before, but it really does. And in a way that's so different from shows, both then and now, which like, you know, makes it, I think stand apart. And I'm saying this as a fan, like before being on the show, I just, whether I consciously noticed that or not, it had to resonate in some way. So yeah, that's, that's my, that's my take on it.
就像它，它立即相关且非常有趣的节目，但它太罕见了，因为它在中心有这样的心，你知道，但我知道这一切以前都被说过了，但它确实有。而且以一种与节目如此不同的方式，无论是当时还是现在，这就像，你知道，使它，我想脱颖而出。而且我是作为一个粉丝说这句话的，就像在参加节目之前，我只是，无论我是否有意识地注意到这一点，它都必须以某种方式产生共鸣。所以是的，那，那是我的，那是我的看法。
Ellie, what are you up to now? Can you share about what you're up to? The last thing I worked on was a movie for Netflix, which is a date TBD is called happiness for beginners. And it's honestly about a woman who finds love. So talk about heart. There you got it. But it's a hiking movie.
艾莉，你现在在忙什么？你能分享一下你在忙什么吗？我最后参与的项目是Netflix的一部电影，日期待定，叫《初学者幸福》。而且它老实说是关于一个找到爱的女人。所以谈谈心。你得到了它。但这是一部徒步旅行电影。
It's based on a book by the same name, happiness for beginners. And we'll wait and see when it is released, but they haven't, they haven't named a release date yet. So that's mostly what I'm working on and figuring out what's going to be next. So that's, that's it from these parts. Well we will let people know when that movie comes out. Thank you, Jen and Angela. Thank you so much for coming on the show today, Ellie.
它基于同名书，《初学者幸福》。我们将拭目以待它何时发布，但他们还没有，他们还没有命名发布日期。所以这就是我主要在忙的事情，并弄清楚接下来会是什么。所以这就是，这就是来自这些部分的。嗯，我们会让人们知道那部电影何时出来。谢谢，珍娜和安吉拉。非常感谢你今天来到节目，艾莉。
Ladies. You're so fun. Yes. You guys, this has been, I was looking forward to this on so many levels. It was such a pleasure chatting with you, but I really wanted, I mean, obviously congratulate you on your book, which is like number one. Like congratulations. That's huge.
女士们。你太有趣了。是的。你们，这已经，我从很多层面期待这个。和你们聊天真是太愉快了，但我真的想要，我的意思是，显然祝贺你们的书，就像第一名。就像恭喜。那太大了。
Thank you. So I mean, you make it look easy. So hats off. I mean, that's really incredible. But thank you very much for having me, you guys. I, I, I adore you. So I was very much looking forward to this. You made my day, Ellie.
谢谢。所以我的意思是，你让它看起来很容易。所以脱帽致敬。我的意思是，那真的不可思议。但非常感谢你们邀请我，你们。我，我，我崇拜你们。所以我非常期待这个。你让我的一天很美好，艾莉。
You made my day. Oh, Angela. You brought me back. I mean, listen. Angela. True her. That's a lot. Oh my Lord.
你让我的一天很美好。哦，安吉拉。你把我带回来了。我的意思是，听着。安吉拉。坚强的人。那很多。哦，我的上帝。
Thank you so much, Ellie. My Lord, my Lanta. Isn't that what they used to say? My Lord, my Lanta. Give me some my Lanta. Love you so much. Thank you ladies. I hope we'll see you soon again in person.
非常感谢你，艾莉。我的上帝，我的兰塔。那不是他们过去常说的吗？我的上帝，我的兰塔。给我一些我的兰塔。非常爱你。谢谢女士们。我希望我们很快能再次亲自见到你们。
I hope we see. I hope I get to see you soon in person too. Well, we are back. That was delightful. I love her. Love her. Jenna, let's get into this episode. Let's do it.
我希望我们看到。我希望我也能很快亲自见到你。嗯，我们回来了。那太愉快了。我爱她。爱她。珍娜，让我们进入这一集。让我们做吧。
I have some stuff about the cold open. I do as well. Who's going first? You go first. Oh, okay. Well, maybe we should describe the cold open. Nah. Skip it.
我有一些关于冷开场的东西。我也有。谁先来？你先来。哦，好的。嗯，也许我们应该描述冷开场。不。跳过它。
You describe it. All right. Everybody is gathered around Oscar's desk. Whenever the writers wanted us to watch something at someone's desk, it was always Oscar's desk. Facts. And what they are watching is a Cookie Monster video, but Cookie Monster has Kevin's voice. Yes.
你描述它。好的。每个人都聚集在奥斯卡的桌子周围。每当编剧想要我们在某人的桌子上看东西时，它总是奥斯卡的桌子。事实。而他们正在看的是一个饼干怪兽视频，但饼干怪兽有凯文的声音。是的。
So, per Randy Cordray, this was actually scene number 15 in the shooting draft. It was not the cold open, but in editing, they did some rearranging. Well, I went to the shooting draft, Jenna. And guess what was the cold open in the shooting draft? What? I mean, I love that I'm saying guess because you're going to be like, I have no idea. You can tell I'm feeling better because everything tickles me. Everything is like wonderful.
根据兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）的说法，这实际上是拍摄剧本中的第15场戏。它原本不是开场冷笑话，但在剪辑时，他们做了一些调整。好吧，我查了拍摄剧本，珍娜。你猜猜拍摄剧本里的开场冷笑话是什么？什么？我是说，我喜欢用“猜猜”这个词，因为你肯定会说，我一点头绪都没有。你能听出来我感觉好多了，因为每件事都让我觉得好笑。每件事都太棒了。
Every little thing about life is making you happy. Yes, it is. Yes. Okay. Here's what the cold open was. Interior conference room morning. Toby is running a meeting. He is energized and excited in a way we've not seen.
生活中的每一件小事都让你感到快乐。是的，确实如此。是的。好吧。开场冷笑话是这样的。室内，会议室，早晨。托比正在主持会议。他表现得精力充沛、兴奋不已，这是我们从未见过的样子。
He holds up a small booklet. Toby says, a citizen's guide to Radon. This book could save your life. Yes. Toby's obsession with Radon. Yes. That was the original cold open. It will eventually end up in the episode, The Chump.
他举起一本小册子。托比说，公民氡气指南。这本书能救你的命。是的。托比对氡气的痴迷。是的。这就是最初的开场冷笑话。它最终出现在了《笨蛋》（The Chump）那一集中。
But the one we went with as Jenna shared was when Oscar dubs Kevin's voice. Jenna, there were many, many alts for this scene. First of all, it started with an Oscar talking head that did not make it to air. This was the Oscar talking head, Oscar. I was listening to a message Kevin left me and I thought for a second it was Cookie Monster. So I edited this together at home. And then that would have led in to the scene with everyone gathered around his computer. Oh, okay.
但正如珍娜所分享的，我们最终采用的是奥斯卡为凯文配音的那一段。珍娜，这一幕有很多很多备选方案。首先，它以奥斯卡的谈话头（talking head）开始，但那段没能播出。这就是奥斯卡的谈话头，奥斯卡说：我正在听凯文给我留的语音留言，有一瞬间我以为是芝麻街的甜饼怪兽。所以我回家把这些剪辑在了一起。然后那会引出大家围在他电脑前的那一幕。哦，好吧。
I know. Fascinating. I think it is. Oh Lord. Here were some of the alts they gave to Brian. Oh my gosh, Jenna. Oscar, I'm going to be late today. I'm stuck in a drive-through behind a bus.
我知道。太迷人了。我觉得是这样。天哪。这是他们给布莱恩的一些备选台词。天哪，珍娜。奥斯卡，我今天会迟到。我被堵在得来速车道里，前面是一辆公交车。
Bye. Hey Oscar, I'm at the dentist. Turns out I have a cavity. Can you save me some cake? Bye. Oscar, I'm pushing the volume on my phone. Do I sound louder? Oscar, do my hands feel sweaty to you?
再见。嘿奥斯卡，我在牙医那儿。结果我长了蛀牙。你能帮我留点蛋糕吗？再见。奥斯卡，我正在调大手机音量。我听起来声音大点了吗？奥斯卡，你觉得我的手出汗了吗？
Wow. Those were all in the shooting draft. That means Brian, as Kevin, read all of those. Yeah. So I wonder how they decided which one was going to win. I bet they just dubbed them all and then sat around and watched them and decided. Well, the two that made it in did crack me up. The first one is Oscar.
哇。这些都在拍摄剧本里。这意味着布莱恩作为凯文，读了所有这些台词。是的。所以我很好奇他们是怎么决定哪一个胜出的。我敢打赌他们只是把它们都配好音，然后坐在一起看，最后做出了决定。嗯，那两个入选的确实让我笑喷了。第一个是奥斯卡。
Toby said he loved my Girl Scout cookies on my chair. Have you seen them? Wait, I'm sitting on them. Bye. And then the second one is Oscar. What's the difference between a chimichanga, a chalupa, and a tostada? Call me back ASAP. Amazing.
托比说他喜欢我椅子上的女童军饼干。你看见了吗？等等，我正坐在它们上面。再见。然后第二个是奥斯卡。奇米查加卷、查鲁帕饼和托斯塔达脆饼之间有什么区别？尽快给我回电话。太棒了。
It's funny. All of that is happening in the scene. But the thing I wrote down in my document is this. I need to talk about Ryan's outfit. I know. That's what I wrote down. He has on an untied bow tie. Here's the crazy thing.
真有趣。所有这些都在那一幕中发生了。但我记录在文档里的是这个。我需要谈谈瑞安的装扮。我知道。这就是我记下来的。他系着一个没系好的领结。最疯狂的是。
I found an interview that Mindy Kaling did for OfficeTelly.com right after this episode aired and she talked about the untied bow tie. Oh, mom detective. Do it. I felt so validated. Do it, mom detective. Do it. She said, quote, I take a lot of pride in the choice of Ryan's undone bow tie, which is the infuriating style of some hipsters and hipster musicians. It has such annoying connotations of I partied so hard.
我找到了一篇明迪·卡灵（Mindy Kaling）在这一集播出后为OfficeTelly.com做的采访，她谈到了那个没系好的领结。哦，妈妈侦探。快说。我感到非常被认可。快说，妈妈侦探。快说。她说，引用一下，“我对瑞安那个没系好的领结的选择感到非常自豪，这正是某些嬉皮士和嬉皮音乐人那种令人恼火的风格。它有一种非常烦人的暗示，就像是‘我派对玩得太疯了’。”
I am this unkempt or I don't even care what anyone thinks of me. I am an iconic last, both of which are perfect for the smug Ryan. Because by the way, it was in the script that he's wearing an untied bow tie. Like this was a Mindy Kaling detail. And I totally noticed it, Mindy. I want to know where Mindy was when she saw someone that looked like that and she was instantly like ticked off. Like, how dare you? Yeah, she was like, Ryan.
“我就是这么邋遢，或者我根本不在乎别人怎么看我。我是一个标志性的懒鬼，这两点对于自以为是的瑞安来说都很完美。”因为顺便说一下，剧本里确实写了他戴着一个没系好的领结。这就像是一个明迪·卡灵式的细节。我完全注意到了，明迪。我想知道明迪是在哪里看到有人看起来那样，然后立刻就感到火大的。就像，你怎么敢？是的，她当时就像，瑞安。
Well, Randy Cordray told me that getting permission to use the Sesame Street characters was not easy. It was a very long process. I remember this, Jenna. I remember there was like Scuttlebutt like, what if we can't get it? They're like being kind of sticklers. He said that it started off really easy and Mindy confirmed this as well, that they had a conference call with the Children's Television Network, which is now called Sesame Street Workshop, asking if they could use Cookie Monster.
嗯，兰迪·科德雷告诉我，获得使用《芝麻街》角色的许可并不容易。这是一个非常漫长的过程。我记得这个，珍娜。我记得当时有传言说，如果我们拿不到许可怎么办？他们有点像是在吹毛求疵。他说最初其实很容易，明迪也证实了这一点，他们和儿童电视网（现在叫芝麻街工作室）进行了一次电话会议，询问是否可以使用甜饼怪兽。
And they had kind of shown them the outline of the script and they were like, yes, you can. But Randy said it was with the caveat that we had to show them the final cut for final approval. But they said, go ahead and shoot it. We think it's going to be okay. Well, I guess after we shot it and showed it to them, they said no. Yeah, that's what I remember. So they set up another conference call with Greg Daniels, Paul Lieberstein, Steve Carell and Randy Cordray with the senior executives at the New York headquarters of Sesame Workshop. Uh-oh.
他们给他们看了剧本大纲，对方说，是的，可以。但兰迪说，前提是我们必须给他们看最终剪辑版以获得最终批准。但他们说，去拍吧。我们觉得应该没问题。嗯，我猜在我们拍完并给他们看之后，他们说不行。是的，这就是我记得的。所以他们和格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）、保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）、史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）以及兰迪·科德雷一起，与芝麻街工作室纽约总部的资深高管们又开了一次电话会议。噢，不。
Greg and Paul said, listen, this parody is really innocent. We are not making fun of Cookie Monster. We're making fun of Kevin's voice. So Randy was on the call. He said he could feel the executives softening to the idea. They're coming around, not quite there yet, until... Dun, dun, dun. Steve Carell volunteered to appear on Sesame Street in the scene of their choosing. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. He said he would be in New York City soon and he would do a cameo. Steve knows how to work it.
格雷格和保罗说，听着，这个模仿真的很无辜。我们不是在取笑甜饼怪兽。我们是在取笑凯文的声音。所以兰迪也在通话中。他说他能感觉到高管们对这个想法有所松动。他们开始接受了，虽然还没完全同意，直到……当当当。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔主动提出要在他们选择的场景中客串出演《芝麻街》。嗯哼。嗯哼。他说他很快会去纽约，他会客串一下。史蒂夫知道怎么搞定这件事。
And they were like, yes, I found his cameo. You did? So we can play it. Oh, cute. Yes. Hi, I'm Steve. And I'm Abby and Elmo's Elmo. And we're here to tell you all about the word vote.
然后他们就说，好的，我找到了他的客串片段。你找到了？那我们可以放出来。哦，可爱。是的。嗨，我是史蒂夫。我是艾比，我是埃尔莫的埃尔莫。我们来这里是为了告诉你们关于“投票”这个词的一切。
Yes, vote. Yes. Let's tell them what vote means. Well, the word vote means to make a choice between two or more things. And right now, we are going to show a vote. What is Elmo going to vote about, Mrs. Steve? Well, we're going to vote to decide what we're going to have for snack time. This is exciting. Elmo can't wait to vote.
是的，投票。是的。让我们告诉他们投票是什么意思。嗯，投票这个词的意思是在两个或更多事物之间做出选择。现在，我们要进行一次投票。埃尔莫要投票决定什么呢，史蒂夫先生？嗯，我们要投票决定零食时间吃什么。这太令人兴奋了。埃尔莫等不及要投票了。
That's adorable. It was so cute. I watched the whole thing. So they're going to vote on whether to have cheese or peanut butter and jelly as a snack. Okay. Very dramatically, there is a late breaking third candidate for snack and it's pizza. Oh, no. And pizza runs away with it. Pizza wins.
太可爱了。真是太可爱了。我看了全过程。所以他们要投票决定是吃奶酪还是花生酱果酱三明治作为零食。好的。非常戏剧性的是，出现了一个迟到的第三位零食候选者，那就是披萨。哦，不。披萨胜出了。披萨赢了。
But it's really cute. But that is why we were able to use Cookie Monster and the Count in our episode because of Steve. Well, that is stinkin' cute. I love that Elmo calls him Mrs. Steve. I know. Kevin is very upset by all of this. Yeah. Yeah.
但这真的很可爱。但这就是为什么我们能在我们的剧集中使用甜饼怪兽和伯爵，多亏了史蒂夫。嗯，那真是太可爱了。我喜欢埃尔莫叫他史蒂夫先生。我知道。凯文对这一切感到非常不安。是的。是的。
I don't know if anyone else has tickled. Dwight says, send me a link to that. And everyone's like, yeah, send me a link. Send me a link. Kevin appeals to Angela, who is beside herself happy. She says, this is my favorite day. And we got a fan question about it from Selena R. in Long Island, New York. In these later episodes, it seems like Angela becomes more emotional and humanized.
我不知道还有没有其他人觉得好笑。德怀特说，给我发个链接。大家都说，是啊，发个链接。发个链接。凯文向安吉拉求助，安吉拉对此感到无比高兴。她说，这是我最喜欢的一天。我们收到了来自纽约长岛的塞琳娜·R（Selena R.）关于此事的粉丝提问。在这些后期的剧集中，安吉拉似乎变得更加情绪化和人性化了。
Do you agree? If so, Angela, how did you interpret this? Now as a viewer and as an actor. In this episode, especially, I felt like I saw so much growth in her character. I couldn't imagine Angela doing some of these scenes in the earlier episodes. Selena, I love this question because as a performer, my backstory for showing more emotion as Angela as the years went on is that she was very guarded in the beginning around the camera crew.
你同意吗？如果是的话，安吉拉，你是怎么解读这一点的？现在作为观众和演员。在这一集中，我特别感觉到她的角色成长了很多。我无法想象安吉拉在早期的剧集中会做出这些举动。塞琳娜，我喜欢这个问题，因为作为一名表演者，我为安吉拉随着岁月流逝表现出更多情感所设定的背景故事是，她在摄像组面前最初是非常防备的。
She is a distrusting person. She doesn't like strangers. This would have been very awkward for her to have these people there every day. I'm sure was very reluctant to participate. And so as the years grew and she became more comfortable, she just let her guard down a little bit more and showed more of her emotions. Right. So it's not like Angela is changing.
她是一个不信任他人的人。她不喜欢陌生人。这些人每天都在这里对她来说会非常尴尬。我相信她非常不情愿参与其中。所以随着岁月的增长，她变得更加自在，她只是稍微放下了防备，表现出了更多的情感。对。所以并不是安吉拉变了。
It's just she's changing how much of herself she's revealing to this crew. Exactly. It's so funny because we never really talked about it. It just kind of happened. Yeah. Naturally. Yeah. For all the characters.
只是她改变了向这个团队展示自己的程度。完全正确。这太有趣了，因为我们从未真正讨论过它。它只是自然而然地发生了。是的。自然地。是的。对于所有角色来说。
Thank you for that question. I thought that was great. Andy has a very exuberant talking head. He's super excited. It's secretary's day. He's made a banner. He's decorated. He said he's so excited for everyone to celebrate Aaron.
谢谢你的提问。我觉得这很好。安迪有一个非常热情的谈话头。他超级兴奋。今天是秘书节。他做了一个横幅。他装饰了一番。他说他非常兴奋，大家都要庆祝艾琳。
He really wanted everyone to know to celebrate her. I don't know what he did. He sent an email blast, a text blast, a good old fashioned talk blast and a snail mail blast. Yeah. Also in his talking head, he says if it weren't for secretaries, he wouldn't have a step mom. Again with Andy sharing random stuff from his past. We got a fan question slash catch from Anne O in Norway. Hi, Anne.
他真的很想让每个人都知道要庆祝她。我不知道他做了什么。他发了电子邮件群发、短信群发、老式的口头群发和纸质邮件群发。是的。在他的谈话头中，他还说如果不是因为秘书，他就不会有继母了。安迪又在分享他过去的一些随机事情了。我们收到了来自挪威的安·O（Anne O）的粉丝提问/发现。嗨，安。
Andy says he has a step mom, but later his parents are still married. What's going on? Welcome, Anne. Welcome to the mystery of Andy's backstory. It's true. I had to say Anne's catch because I think we were all thinking it. Yeah. Well, another thing's happening today.
安迪说他有一个继母，但后来他的父母仍然结婚。这是怎么回事？欢迎，安。欢迎来到安迪背景故事的谜团。这是真的。我必须说出安的发现，因为我想我们都在想这个问题。是的。嗯，今天还有别的事情发生。
Pam is back. She's back from her maternity leave. She is going to put a photo on her desk of Cece at two minutes. That was a photo of my real niece, Cece. Oh, cute. She's also going to notice that her plant died. Jim said he didn't even know it existed. That made me laugh.
帕姆回来了。她休完产假回来了。她要在桌子上放一张西西（Cece）两分钟大的照片。那是我的亲侄女西西的照片。哦，可爱。她还会注意到她的植物死了。吉姆说他甚至不知道它的存在。这让我笑了。
Because I feel like my husband would do that. I have all of these plants. Whenever I travel for work, I'm like, okay, two things. Change out my hummingbird feeders and my plants. Yeah. I always am not sure what I'm going to get when I come home. Well, Dwight said he chose to let it die. Welcome back, Pam.
因为我觉得我丈夫也会那样。我有所有这些植物。每当我出差工作时，我都会说，好吧，两件事。换掉我的蜂鸟喂食器和我的植物。是的。我回家时总是不确定会看到什么。嗯，德怀特说他选择让它死掉。欢迎回来，帕姆。
Fan question from Caitlyn C in Iowa. Is this proof that Pam was buying all the plants for the front desk? Oh, I like to think that. I do too. Well, there was more to the scene. At 25 seconds, what would have happened, it was a deleted scene, is that Pam would find a very old box of cupcakes. That was a gift, like a baby gift, that was left on her desk for weeks.
来自爱荷华州凯特琳·C（Caitlyn C）的粉丝提问。这是否证明帕姆一直在为前台买所有的植物？哦，我喜欢这样想。我也是。嗯，这一幕还有更多内容。在25秒时，本来会发生的事情，这是一个被删减的片段，是帕姆会发现一个非常旧的纸杯蛋糕盒。那是一个礼物，就像婴儿礼物，在她的桌子上放了几个星期。
It was covered in fruit flies, and she had one of her drawers that was full of maggots. My gosh. Mm-hmm. Pam's dialogue would have been, ugh, who left cupcakes on my desk for six weeks? My drawer is filled with maggots, to which Dwight jumps up, runs over to the drawer, protectively, and says, those are mine. I was breeding maggots for personal use. I have nothing to do with the fruit flies, though.
上面爬满了果蝇，她的一个抽屉里全是蛆。天哪。嗯哼。帕姆的台词本来是，呃，谁把纸杯蛋糕放在我桌上六个星期了？我的抽屉里全是蛆，德怀特跳起来，跑向抽屉，保护性地说，那是我的。我正在培育蛆供个人使用。不过，我和果蝇没关系。
Did we shoot that? Yes. I have no memory of that. It's in deleted scenes. That's crazy to me. Crazy. But this is what was happening on Pam's desk while she was away. Her plants were dying.
我们拍了吗？是的。我对此毫无记忆。它在被删减的片段里。这对我来说太疯狂了。疯狂。但这就是帕姆不在时，她的桌子上发生的事情。她的植物在枯萎。
There were fruit flies and maggots in her drawer. Randy did share, for this deleted scene, we use Bob Dunn's animal rentals for flies and maggots. Trainers were Megan Frazier and Kevin Kinzer. So now, Andy is really going to do everything he can to have Erin have this great secretary's day. And that starts with going to Michael and asking Michael, what do you have planned? What are you going to do for her? And Michael says, he's going to give her $15, to which Andy says, I think maybe step it up. Like, why don't you take her to lunch?
她的抽屉里有果蝇和蛆。兰迪分享说，对于这个被删减的片段，我们使用了鲍勃·邓恩（Bob Dunn）的动物租赁公司提供的苍蝇和蛆。训练师是梅根·弗雷泽（Megan Frazier）和凯文·金泽（Kevin Kinzer）。所以现在，安迪真的要尽他所能让艾琳度过一个美好的秘书节。这始于他去找迈克尔，问迈克尔，你有什么计划？你打算为她做什么？迈克尔说，他要给她15美元，安迪说，我觉得也许再加点。比如，你为什么不带她去吃午饭？
Oh, Michael does not want to spend a lunch with Erin. Oh, no. It's like Andy said, I think you should get a root canal. It's so true. Michael's expression. Well, this scene was bigger and it explained the whole $15 thing. Yeah, that was a very specific amount of money. Well, it's in deleted scenes.
哦，迈克尔不想和艾琳一起吃午饭。哦，不。就像安迪说的，我觉得你应该去根管治疗。太对了。迈克尔的表情。嗯，这一幕本来更长，解释了15美元的事情。是的，那是一个非常具体的金额。嗯，它在被删减的片段里。
Michael explains the $15 and it leads into a Pam talking head. I think we should hear it. I was just wondering what you had planned for secretary's day. Oh, I'm going to give Erin $15. Wow. Why? Because that's what I always used to do with Pam. See, Pam decided that she would rather have the cash value of her half of lunch were I to take her out.
迈克尔解释了15美元，然后引出了帕姆的一个谈话头。我想我们应该听听。我只是想知道你为秘书节准备了什么。哦，我要给艾琳15美元。哇。为什么？因为我以前总是这样对待帕姆。你看，帕姆决定她宁愿要我带她出去吃午饭的一半现金价值。
So she promises every year to take that money, go to Cooper's and buy herself a Sunday. Yeah. I can't believe that worked. That's pretty great. I know. I loved it. Well, I have a background catch for this scene. You know, earlier at reception, one of the gifts that Erin got for secretary's day was like a little stuffed dog.
所以她每年都承诺把那笔钱拿去库珀餐厅给自己买个圣代。是的。我不敢相信这招管用。那太棒了。我知道。我喜欢它。嗯，这一幕我有一个背景发现。你知道，早些时候在前台，艾琳收到的秘书节礼物之一是一个小毛绒狗。
Did you notice? Oh, yeah. Well, at two minutes and 33 seconds in the background through the window, I think Erin is like pretending to give her stuffed dog a drink of water. Oh, no way. From a cup. And then it's talking on the phone. She's doing all this business with her little stuffed dog. Well, Andy taped the phone to its head earlier and then she waves the dog's paw at Michael.
你注意到了吗？哦，是的。嗯，在两分33秒，背景里透过窗户，我想艾琳是在假装给她的毛绒狗喂水。哦，不会吧。用杯子。然后它在打电话。她用她的小毛绒狗做了所有这些动作。嗯，安迪早些时候把电话粘在它的头上，然后她挥动狗爪子向迈克尔示意。
Yeah. She really is loving that stuffed animal. Well, on a rewatch, you can watch the stuffed dog show through the window during this scene. I need to see it. Michael is persuaded by Andy and he's going to invite Erin to lunch. He suggests Hayworths and Michael is like, oh, he's not feeling it, but ultimately that's where they go. I could not find a real Hayworths in Scranton. Same.
是的。她真的很喜欢那个毛绒玩具。嗯，重看的时候，你可以在这一幕中透过窗户看到毛绒狗。我需要看看。迈克尔被安迪说服了，他要邀请艾琳去吃午饭。他建议去海沃斯（Hayworths），迈克尔当时，哦，他没感觉，但最终他们还是去了那里。我在斯克兰顿找不到真正的海沃斯餐厅。我也是。
Looked it up, couldn't find it. I did find a great article on Mental Floss that gives you a Dunder Mifflin tour of Scranton of all the places that actually exist and that you can go. I found that same thing too. And Hayworths is not on the list. Two ladies at Google. Look at us go. Googling the same things. We have a few catches in this scene.
查过了，没找到。我确实在Mental Floss上找到了一篇很棒的文章，它为你提供了斯克兰顿的办公室之旅，列出了所有真实存在且你可以去的地方。我也发现了同样的东西。海沃斯不在名单上。谷歌上的两位女士。看看我们。在谷歌上搜索同样的东西。这一幕我们有几个发现。
Oh, let's hear it. At three minutes and one second, when Michael is approaching Erin's desk, the front door is closed. Okay. But at three minutes and nine seconds, the front door is open. Continuity catch, folks. Ding, ding, ding. Also, through that door, there is a picture on the wall that I have personally never noticed before. It's some sort of, I don't know what, a mountainy or something.
哦，让我们听听。在三分零一秒，当迈克尔接近艾琳的桌子时，前门是关着的。好的。但在三分零九秒，前门是开着的。连贯性发现，伙计们。叮叮叮。此外，透过那扇门，墙上有一张我个人从未注意到的照片。那是什么，我不知道，山之类的。
It's hazy in the background. Did we always have a picture there? Why is this the first time I'm seeing it? I don't know. But here is the major catch from the scene. And this is truly major. And it is, in fact, also a fan mail flurry. It's a fan mail flurry.
背景里很模糊。我们那里一直有照片吗？为什么这是我第一次看到它？我不知道。但这是这一幕的主要发现。这确实是重大的。而且，事实上，这也是一阵粉丝邮件狂潮。这是一阵粉丝邮件狂潮。
Yay! I love my new sting. At three minutes and four seconds, Anna H. from Columbus, Ohio, Rudy D. from Utah, and Amanda H. from Boston, and many more all said, Erin is wearing purple flower earrings in this episode. Are they the same earrings that Pam wore in New York for art school? What? Yes, they are, folks. They recycled Pam's art school earrings and they put them on Erin for secretary's day.
耶！我喜欢我的新音效。在三分零四秒，来自俄亥俄州哥伦布市的安娜·H（Anna H.）、犹他州的鲁迪·D（Rudy D.）、波士顿的阿曼达·H（Amanda H.）以及许多其他人都在说，艾琳在这一集中戴着紫色花朵耳环。它们是帕姆在纽约艺术学校时戴的那些耳环吗？什么？是的，它们是，伙计们。他们回收了帕姆的艺术学校耳环，并在秘书节那天给艾琳戴上了。
I took a side-by-side screenshot. These are the earrings that Pam was wearing in the hallway in weight loss part two. What a fantastic catch. I'm applauding it. Super well done. I'm going to show you the pic. I want to see the pic. Oh my gosh.
我拍了一张并排截图。这些是帕姆在《减肥》第二部分走廊里戴的耳环。多么棒的发现。我为它鼓掌。做得非常好。我要给你看照片。我想看照片。天哪。
Exactly the same. Yep. What's going to happen next? She's going to wear Meredith's vest? What's happening? Oh my gosh. I would love for Erin to wear Meredith's vest. That would be incredible.
完全一样。是的。接下来会发生什么？她要穿梅雷迪思的背心吗？发生了什么？天哪。我很乐意看到艾琳穿梅雷迪思的背心。那太不可思议了。
In the kitchen, there's some people enjoying Kevin's Cookie Monster bit. It would be Meredith and Daryl. They have cookies out. They tempt him to have one. So then Daryl can just go, mwah, mwah, mwah, mwah. Yes. Kevin is starting to clue in that maybe they're not making fun of Cookie Monster. Maybe they're making fun of him.
在厨房里，有些人正在享受凯文的甜饼怪兽片段。那是梅雷迪思和达里尔。他们拿出了饼干。他们诱惑他吃一个。这样达里尔就可以说，姆，姆，姆，姆。是的。凯文开始意识到也许他们不是在取笑甜饼怪兽。也许他们是在取笑他。
At first, he doesn't want to eat the cookie. He is suspicious. He says, you just brought those cookies so that I'll eat one and you can make fun of me. And Daryl's like, I brought these cookies because it's my birthday. Fan question from Timber Bee in Tennessee. Hold on. It's secretary's day, but it's also Daryl's birthday.
起初，他不想吃饼干。他很怀疑。他说，你们带这些饼干来只是为了让我吃一个，然后你们就可以取笑我。达里尔说，我带这些饼干是因为今天是我的生日。来自田纳西州Timber Bee的粉丝提问。等等。今天是秘书节，但也是达里尔的生日。
Why didn't the PPC throw him a birthday party? Poor Daryl. No birthday cake for him. He needs a fudgy the whale. I don't think it was his birthday. Same. I think he was just making it up to make Kevin eat the cookie. Kevin is going to go to Gabe.
为什么派对策划委员会（PPC）没有为他举办生日派对？可怜的达里尔。没有生日蛋糕给他。他需要一个鲸鱼形状的冰淇淋蛋糕。我不认为那是他的生日。我也是。我觉得他只是编出来的，为了让凯文吃饼干。凯文要去找盖博（Gabe）。
He's going to show Gabe the video. I think he wants to know, are they making fun of me? Is this appropriate? And Gabe is not having it. Oh, Gabe lights up. He's finally got his cause. Something that will demand respect from the coworkers. His talking had us hilarious to me.
他要给盖博看视频。我想他想知道，他们是在取笑我吗？这合适吗？盖博对此不买账。哦，盖博亮了。他终于有了他的事业。一些能要求同事尊重的东西。他的谈话头对我来说太搞笑了。
He said that his beginning there has been a little bit of a fiasco. I loved it when he said some of them still think I'm the IT guy. That just cracked me up. I mean, some of them probably creed and merited. Have not paid attention. But the cookie monster thing is Gabe's opportunity. He's really going to show them that he's the authority figure. And this starts a whole storyline.
他说他刚到那里时有点像一场闹剧。我喜欢他说有些人还以为我是IT人员。这让我笑喷了。我是说，有些人可能克里德和梅雷迪思。没注意。但甜饼怪兽的事情是盖博的机会。他真的要向他们展示他是权威人物。这开启了整个故事情节。
Well, lady, we got a fan question from KCA in Canada. Am I the only one who thinks everybody is being too mean to Kevin? Maybe I'm just too sensitive and have seen the episode too many times, but rewatching it now, it feels genuinely kind of mean. Thoughts? Casey, I'm glad you wrote in because I also kind of thought like, Gabe is right, he should shut this down. This is like, not cool to do to your coworker.
嗯，女士，我们收到了来自加拿大KCA的粉丝提问。我是唯一一个认为每个人对凯文都太刻薄的人吗？也许我太敏感了，这一集看了太多遍，但现在重看，感觉真的很刻薄。有什么想法？凯西，我很高兴你写信来，因为我也觉得，盖博是对的，他应该阻止这件事。这对你的同事来说太不酷了。
I'm with you. I'm with you too. I think it went across the line, but I will say this. I imagine everyone in that office hits their breaking point with Kevin. I mean, he did walk up to Pam and pretend to be a baby crying to see if her boobs would produce milk. Yes. So probably there is part of them that just delighted in it for a little bit,
我和你一样。我也一样。我觉得这越界了，但我会说这一点。我想办公室里的每个人对凯文都到了忍无可忍的地步。我是说，他确实走到帕姆面前，假装成婴儿哭，看看她的胸部会不会产奶。是的。所以可能他们内心深处有一部分确实为此感到了一点点快乐，
but I think they went too far. Yeah. Well, I totally get why the characters at Dunder Mifflin would delight in this parody video. But at the same time, Casey, I'm with you. Yeah, I see it. Well, Gabe is going to address the bullpen. He's going to tell them that he forbids anyone from discussing
但我认为他们做得太过分了。是的。嗯，我完全明白为什么邓德·米夫林的角色会喜欢这个模仿视频。但同时，凯西，我和你一样。是的，我看到了。嗯，盖博要向办公区讲话。他要告诉他们，他禁止任何人讨论
or sharing the parody video, and that is coming from corporate, so they better listen to it. Mm-hmm. It doesn't seem like anyone's going to listen to it. It really doesn't. Well, now we are in the car on the way to Aaron's secretary's day lunch. Michael is driving. He would rather not talk.
或分享那个模仿视频，这是来自总部的命令，所以他们最好听着。嗯哼。看起来没人会听。真的没人听。嗯，现在我们在去艾琳秘书节午餐的路上。迈克尔在开车。他宁愿不说话。
He's hoping that he could listen to his audiobook, which is a novelization of the movie Precious, based on the novel Push by Sapphire. Per Randy Cordray, all of these driving scenes were filmed on Burbank Boulevard near Balboa Park, which was our go-to street. There's no palm trees on the street. I love that it was someone's job to drive around the vicinity of where we shoot, looking for stretches of road with no palm trees.
他希望他能听他的有声读物，那是电影《珍爱人生》（Precious）的小说版，基于萨菲尔（Sapphire）的小说《推》（Push）。根据兰迪·科德雷的说法，所有这些驾驶场景都是在巴尔博亚公园附近的伯班克大道上拍摄的，那是我们的首选街道。街上没有棕榈树。我喜欢有人负责在拍摄地附近开车，寻找没有棕榈树的路段。
Like, that was their job. They're like, go find me a street with no palm trees. This was the main one. As I watched the scene, I looked for palm trees. There weren't any. But I did see the mountains in the background. Mm-hmm. Yeah.
就像，那是他们的工作。他们就像，给我找一条没有棕榈树的街道。这是主要的一条。当我观看这一幕时，我寻找棕榈树。根本没有。但我确实看到了背景里的山。嗯哼。是的。
I mean, you're not going to find no mountains and no palm trees. I know. We just went with no palm trees. Steve was not actually driving in the scene. The car was being towed behind one of those camera insert cars. And Randy shared that we used lipstick cameras that were suction cupped to the windshield. That's how we shot it. Randy also shared that lipstick cameras were often problematic.
我是说，你不可能找不到山，也不可能找不到棕榈树。我知道。我们只是选择了没有棕榈树的。史蒂夫在这一幕中并没有真正开车。车是被拖在那些摄像机插入车后面的。兰迪分享说，我们使用了吸盘吸在挡风玻璃上的口红摄像机。这就是我们拍摄的方式。兰迪还分享说，口红摄像机通常有问题。
And whenever we could have a camera operator in a vehicle with us, that was preferred. But if you wanted to get people from the front, you had to use these lipstick cameras. But he said we had a special camera technician named Tim Arashbin, I hope I'm saying your last name right, who was an absolute master of these lipstick cameras. And we actually rarely had problems, thanks to Tim. So thank you, Tim. Thank you, Tim. We use those lipstick cameras a lot.
每当我们能有摄像师和我们一起在车里时，那是首选。但如果你想从前面拍摄，你就必须使用这些口红摄像机。但他提到我们有一位名叫蒂姆·阿拉什宾（Tim Arashbin，希望我没念错你的姓）的特殊摄像技术员，他是这些口红摄像机的绝对大师。多亏了蒂姆，我们实际上很少遇到问题。所以谢谢你，蒂姆。谢谢你，蒂姆。我们经常使用那些口红摄像机。
We did. So there's a lot of the scene in the deleted scenes on the DVD. Guess who narrates the book? Oh, I know this. I know this. In the script, they had a suggestion of someone, but that is not who narrated it when we filmed. Okay. I know who they put in the script.
我们确实用了。所以DVD的被删减片段里有很多这一幕。猜猜谁给这本书配音？哦，我知道这个。我知道。在剧本里，他们有一个人的建议，但那不是我们拍摄时配音的人。好的。我知道他们在剧本里写了谁。
It was David Hyde Pierce. David Hyde Pierce. Exactly. Who ended up doing it? Our editor, Dave Rogers. Oh my gosh, that's perfect. I love it. It was fun to hear his voice.
是戴维·海德·皮尔斯（David Hyde Pierce）。戴维·海德·皮尔斯。完全正确。最后是谁做的？我们的剪辑师，戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）。天哪，那太完美了。我喜欢。听到他的声音很有趣。
The other thing I loved about the deleted scenes for this is that Erin has a talking head where she explains how she is coming up with conversation topics. So she has things to talk about. Let's hear it. I really want to impress Michael and I don't want to take any chances. So I went to a website that listed hundreds of interesting conversation starters. And I'll just break them out whenever there's a pause or even maybe if there's not. Because bosses like women who can talk at length on things.
关于这一点的被删减片段，我喜欢的另一件事是艾琳有一个谈话头，她解释了她是如何想出谈话话题的。所以她有话可说。让我们听听。我真的很想给迈克尔留下深刻印象，我不想冒任何风险。所以我去了一个网站，上面列出了数百个有趣的谈话开头。每当有停顿时，我就会拿出来说，甚至可能在没有停顿时也说。因为老板喜欢能长篇大论谈论事情的女性。
So that would have played before the car scene. And while she's searching on this website for these talking points, all of these advertisements keep popping up, these pop-up ads, and she's having a hard time clicking on her article. It's just a funny background detail. It's at two minutes, 25 seconds. Randy shared with us that all of the motion graphics were created by Henry Sane. Wow. Well, you're going to see a few of these conversation starters coming up in the car.
所以那本来会在车内场景之前播放。当她在网站上搜索这些谈话要点时，所有的广告不断弹出，这些弹出式广告，她很难点击她的文章。这只是一个有趣的背景细节。在两分25秒。兰迪和我们分享说，所有的动态图形都是由亨利·塞恩（Henry Sane）创作的。哇。嗯，你会在车里看到几个这样的谈话开头。
Erin says, so what decade would you have chosen to be a teenager? And then we're going to get to the restaurant for a very awkward lunch. And Erin is going to hit them with this. Do you have a favorite age or month? Michael does not know what to do with this. She goes on to say, how many pillows do you sleep on at night? Well, you know, in the script. Michael had a response to that that got cut out in editing.
艾琳说，那么你会选择哪个十年作为青少年时期？然后我们要去餐厅吃一顿非常尴尬的午餐。艾琳要用这个来对付他们。你有最喜欢的年龄或月份吗？迈克尔不知道该怎么处理这个。她继续说，你晚上睡几个枕头？嗯，你知道，在剧本里。迈克尔对此有一个回应，但在剪辑中被删掉了。
Oh, what'd he say? Michael says, none, just my body pillow. And then he changes the subject to Andy. But that line did not make it in the final cut. But I think that's very funny. I just imagine Michael always sleeping on that little bench at the end of his bed. It's hard to picture him in the actual bed after that scene. I know.
哦，他说了什么？迈克尔说，一个都没有，只有我的身体枕头。然后他把话题转到了安迪身上。但那句台词没能进入最终剪辑。但我认为那非常有趣。我只是想象迈克尔总是睡在他床尾的那张小长凳上。在那一幕之后，很难想象他睡在真正的床上。我知道。
Dinner party. Well, Erin is going to continue to overshare, if you will, at this lunch. She's talking and talking. She can't stop. Yeah, she says she used to work at a Taco Bell Express, but she couldn't hack it when it became a full Taco Bell. It was just too stressful. We had a fan question from Beth W in New York City who loves that line,
晚宴。嗯，艾琳要继续过度分享，如果你愿意的话，在这次午餐上。她一直在说，一直在说。她停不下来。是的，她说她以前在塔可钟快餐店工作，但当它变成全功能的塔可钟时，她应付不来。那太有压力了。我们收到了来自纽约市贝丝·W（Beth W）的粉丝提问，她喜欢那句台词，
wants to know who wrote that amazing joke. Mindy Kaling said that Danny Chun wrote the Taco Bell Express line and it's one of her favorites in the episode. I looked it up, the difference between a Taco Bell Express and a Taco Bell. And I see why it might be more stressful for Erin. Taco Bell Express, if my memory is correct, there's no seating area. No. It is to serve, quote, hungry customers on the go.
想知道是谁写了那个精彩的笑话。明迪·卡灵说丹尼·春（Danny Chun）写了塔可钟快餐店那句台词，这是她在这一集中最喜欢的台词之一。我查了一下，塔可钟快餐店和塔可钟之间的区别。我明白为什么这对艾琳来说压力更大了。塔可钟快餐店，如果我的记忆没错，没有座位区。没有。它是为了服务，引用，“饥饿的顾客在路上”。
It's a grab-and-go. And it also has a smaller menu. It's just the tacos and burritos. And so, yeah, if you went from grab-and-go to a seated restaurant, when I worked in fast food, I have to say, like 50% of it is just cleaning up that dining room. I bet, you know? People are messy.
它是即拿即走的。它还有一个更小的菜单。只有塔可饼和卷饼。所以，是的，如果你从即拿即走变成了坐下来的餐厅，当我在快餐店工作时，我不得不说，50%的时间只是在清理那个餐厅。我敢打赌，你知道吗？人们很乱。
People are messy. You know, the trash cans say thank you. And I used to say, you know, that's for you, the guest. They're not thanking me, the employees, for throwing your stuff away. They're thanking you. That's why carry your stuff over and throw it out on your way out. Maybe trash cans should have a longer message. Like, thank you for not being a total A-hole and putting your trash where you're supposed to put it.
人们很乱。你知道，垃圾桶上写着谢谢。我过去常说，你知道，那是给你的，客人。他们不是在感谢我，员工，清理你的东西。他们是在感谢你。这就是为什么把你的东西带过去，在离开的路上扔掉。也许垃圾桶应该有一个更长的信息。比如，谢谢你没有成为一个彻头彻尾的混蛋，把你的垃圾放在你应该放的地方。
It's literally on your way out of the restaurant. You have to pass by it anyway. Clean up after yourselves. If you make the mess, clean it up. My gosh, how hard is that? I don't even know where we are now. I do, I do. Okay, so this scene, Jenna was even bigger of Aaron just talking and talking.
它就在你离开餐厅的路上。你无论如何都要经过它。清理干净。如果你制造了混乱，就清理干净。天哪，那有多难？我甚至不知道我们现在在哪里。我知道，我知道。好的，所以这一幕，珍娜，艾琳一直在说一直在说，本来更长。
There was part of it that just really cracked me up. It's in deleted scenes. It's about what's in her purse. You have to hear it. My foster home, I never had a desk. So it's like, I don't mean that I didn't like my foster home. I did like it. I just didn't have a desk there.
有一部分真的让我笑喷了。它在被删减的片段里。是关于她钱包里有什么。你必须听听。我的寄养家庭，我从来没有书桌。所以就像，我不是说我不喜欢我的寄养家庭。我喜欢。我只是那里没有书桌。
So, sorry. I know, I feel weird. I think I'm nervous and you're looking at me like I'm weird. But my blood sugar is really low. You know, I didn't have my Luna bar this morning. I thought I put my Luna bar in my purse. But it turns out I put my TV remote instead. You ever see?
所以，抱歉。我知道，我感觉很奇怪。我想我很紧张，你看着我好像我很奇怪。但我的血糖真的很低。你知道，我今天早上没吃我的Luna能量棒。我以为我把Luna能量棒放在钱包里了。但结果我放的是电视遥控器。你见过吗？
There's no woman nutritious. Did you want me to take that? Oh, I just wanted you to know it was real. Okay. No pholic acid in that. Can you imagine eating your TV remote for breakfast? I don't know if it would kill you, but it wouldn't even taste good to begin with. But I don't know.
没有女人有营养。你想让我拿走吗？哦，我只是想让你知道它是真的。好的。里面没有叶酸。你能想象早餐吃你的电视遥控器吗？我不知道它会不会杀了你，但它甚至不好吃。但我不知道。
There's so many things that are nice about being a receptionist that I can't just pick one and say that it's my favorite. But you probably feel the same way about being a boss. You can't pick one. Did you have a favorite age? A month. An age or month? Yeah, like a favorite month. April when I was seven.
作为接待员有很多美好的事情，我不能只选一个说它是我的最爱。但你可能作为老板也有同样的感觉。你不能选一个。你有最喜欢的年龄吗？月份。年龄或月份？是的，比如最喜欢的月份。我七岁时的四月。
I don't have a favorite month now. It's sort of like every month is different. I could listen to it forever. It's so delightful. It's such a wonderful free association. She holds up the remote control. She fishes it out of her bag. And the look on Steve's face is Michael.
我现在没有最喜欢的月份。就像每个月都不一样。我可以永远听下去。太令人愉快了。这是一种美妙的自由联想。她举起遥控器。她从包里掏出来。史蒂夫脸上看着迈克尔的表情。
And he's like, what do you want me to do with it? What do I do with all of this? We got a fan question from Jenna R. in Los Angeles, California. Hi, Jenna. Where did they film Michael and Aaron's lunch scene? It was filmed at a restaurant in Encino called Boca, which has since closed. It is now called Monaco Encino. And Randy even sent us a photo from their location scout.
他就像，你想让我拿它做什么？我该怎么处理所有这些？我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州洛杉矶珍娜·R（Jenna R.）的粉丝提问。嗨，珍娜。他们在哪里拍摄迈克尔和艾琳的午餐场景？它是在恩西诺一家叫Boca的餐厅拍摄的，现在已经关门了。现在叫Monaco Encino。兰迪甚至给我们发了一张他们勘景时的照片。
So what they would have done a week prior to an episode where we have to shoot something on location, everybody would get in a little van, the director, the writer, the producers, the camera operators. And they would go around to like three or four restaurants that are options to shoot at that our locations manager Kyle Alexander would have found. And they would sit in them and they would talk about like, we could put the camera here. This is what you would see if you put the camera here in this location. And then after that, they'd pick the one they like. Randy sent us a picture from the location scout.
所以他们会在拍摄外景的一周前做些什么，每个人都会坐进一辆小货车，导演、编剧、制片人、摄像师。他们会去三四家餐厅，那是我们的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大（Kyle Alexander）找到的拍摄选项。他们会坐在里面，谈论比如，我们可以把摄像机放在这里。如果你把摄像机放在这个位置，你会看到什么。然后在那之后，他们会挑选他们喜欢的那个。兰迪给我们发了一张勘景时的照片。
You can see Steve in it. You can see our first AD Rusty talking about how they might shoot the scene in the background. And then Randy is sitting at a table pretending to be Michael. And our second AD, Jenny O'Keefe, is sitting pretending to be Aaron. Oh, I love that. It just warmed my heart. Oh, we'll have to put it in stories. Definitely. Well, I think we should take a break because when we come back, Michael is going to put his foot in his mouth.
你可以看到史蒂夫在里面。你可以看到我们的第一助理导演拉斯蒂（Rusty）在背景里谈论他们可能如何拍摄这一幕。然后兰迪坐在桌子旁假装是迈克尔。我们的第二助理导演珍妮·奥基夫（Jenny O'Keefe）坐着假装是艾琳。哦，我喜欢那个。它温暖了我的心。哦，我们必须把它放在故事里。绝对的。嗯，我觉得我们应该休息一下，因为当我们回来时，迈克尔要说错话了。
Oh my gosh, he sure is. And Aaron is going to have quite the reaction. We're back. Aaron says, tell me about Andy before I met him. Oh, no. She's got like those dreamy eyes. Michael's like, let's see, Andy plays the banjo. She's like, yeah, I love that.
天哪，他确实会。艾琳会有相当大的反应。我们回来了。艾琳说，告诉我关于安迪在我认识他之前的事。哦，不。她有那种梦幻般的眼神。迈克尔说，让我想想，安迪会弹班卓琴。她说，是的，我喜欢那个。
Other than the fact that he dated Angela, I don't think he's a snappy dresser. Aaron's like, what? And then Michael has what is my favorite line of the whole episode. Same. He says, I don't think he's the best dresser. Reminds me of Easter. I can't unsee this now. All of his outfits are like pastel and like beige and pinks and light blues. He does dress like Easter.
除了他曾和安吉拉约会过，我不认为他是个时髦的穿衣者。艾琳说，什么？然后迈克尔说了整集中我最喜欢的台词。我也是。他说，我不认为他是最好的穿衣者。让我想起复活节。我现在无法忘记这一点。他所有的衣服都像柔和的颜色，像米色、粉色和浅蓝色。他穿得确实像复活节。
He does. But Aaron is like, that's not what I meant. Yeah. He's like, I don't know about Angela. At the same time, the waiter has come by to drop off their food. Yeah. He's like, here we go. Hot plate. And all of this chaos is starting to happen.
他确实。但艾琳说，我不是那个意思。是的。他说，我不确定安吉拉的事。与此同时，服务员过来放下他们的食物。是的。他说，我们来了。热盘子。所有这些混乱开始发生。
Michael is not picking up on it. Instead, he is frustrated that he asked for pickles, but there's only like five or six on this plate. To which the waiter says, I will bring you a bowl of pickles. Yeah. And then Aaron is going to hide inside of her hair. Yes. This is a shooting draft.
迈克尔没有察觉到。相反，他很沮丧，因为他要了泡菜，但盘子里只有五六个。服务员说，我会给你拿一碗泡菜。是的。然后艾琳要躲进她的头发里。是的。这是拍摄剧本。
It specifically said that Aaron covers her face with her hair. Yes. I have a fun catch. The waiter in the scene was played by our writer, Aaron Schur. You guys know him as the master of the cold opens. Yeah. He was the go-to guy for cold opens and gave us some of our most famous cold opens. Yes.
它明确写着艾琳用头发遮住脸。是的。我有一个有趣的发现。这一幕里的服务员是由我们的编剧亚伦·舒尔（Aaron Schur）扮演的。你们知道他是开场冷笑话的大师。是的。他是开场冷笑话的首选，给了我们一些最著名的开场冷笑话。是的。
The Kevin spilling the chili. He wrote that. He wrote the speed meter where everyone's trying to run in front to see how fast they can run. She said that Aaron getting cast as the waiter happened the day before we were set to shoot these restaurant scenes. She said at first they were going to cast like a young actor, but everybody just looked too Hollywood. This was supposed to be a restaurant in Scranton.
凯文洒辣椒。他写的。他写了速度计，每个人都试图跑在前面看他们能跑多快。她说艾琳被选为服务员发生在我们准备拍摄这些餐厅场景的前一天。她说起初他们打算选一个年轻演员，但每个人看起来都太好莱坞了。这本来应该是斯克兰顿的一家餐厅。
And so then in the writer's room, they pitched maybe it would be really funny if the waiter in the restaurant were like really, really, really, really old. She said, quote, like the night at the end of Indiana Jones and the last crusade. Oh my gosh. Super old. That's crazy old. But Steve Carell thought that might be distracting to the scene. So they decided to cast someone who was not too young and not too old.
所以后来在编剧室，他们提议如果餐厅里的服务员真的很老很老很老很老会很有趣。她说，引用，“就像《夺宝奇兵3：圣战奇兵》结尾的那个骑士。”天哪。超级老。那老得疯狂。但史蒂夫·卡瑞尔认为那可能会分散场景的注意力。所以他们决定选一个不太年轻也不太老的人。
And right at that moment of making that decision, Mindy said that our writer, Aaron Schur, got up, walked across the room and went to the bathroom. And everyone was like, how about Aaron? Oh my gosh. He is neither too old or too young. This is a great origin story of how did you get cast on the office? I had to pee and I walked by the writer's room. So Mindy said that he read for it.
就在做出那个决定的那一刻，明迪说我们的编剧亚伦·舒尔站起来，穿过房间去洗手间。每个人都说，亚伦怎么样？天哪。他既不太老也不太年轻。这是一个关于你是如何被选入《办公室》的伟大起源故事。我得去尿尿，我路过编剧室。所以明迪说他试镜了。
He got the part. She also pointed out that he is a trained actor. Well, I reached out to Aaron Schur to ask him about this story and he confirms it. But he thinks that there might be something else at play, which was that in the weeks before this moment, he decided to grow a beard. He thinks maybe the beard had something to do with it and he's going to explain why. Hello office ladies. It's Aaron Schur.
他得到了这个角色。她还指出他是一位受过训练的演员。嗯，我联系了亚伦·舒尔问他这个故事，他证实了。但他认为可能还有别的事情在起作用，那就是在这一刻之前的几周，他决定留胡子。他认为也许胡子和这件事有关，他要解释原因。你好，办公室女士们。我是亚伦·舒尔。
I'm going to tell you the exciting story about how I became a waiter on the office. I had done a little bit of acting, but mostly I was a standup and improviser, a street performer, even a circus clown. And the audiences all said pretty much the same thing to me, which is you should be a writer. So that's what I did because I'm more of a back office sort of guy. But as you know, Dunder Mifflin has the annex, which is there just so that people like Mindy, Paul and BJ, who are all writer actors, they had somewhere to be behind a door. So there was a reason why we didn't wonder where they were when they were actually in the writer's room making the show.
我要讲一个关于我如何成为《办公室》里服务员的激动人心的故事。我之前演过一点戏，但主要是做单口喜剧和即兴表演，当过街头艺人，甚至做过马戏团小丑。观众们对我说的话几乎都一样，那就是你应该去当编剧。所以我照做了，因为我更适合做幕后工作。但你们知道，邓德·米夫林公司有个附楼，之所以存在就是为了让像敏迪、保罗和BJ这样既是编剧又是演员的人，能有个躲在门后的地方。所以，当他们实际上在编剧室写剧本时，我们没去想他们在哪儿，这是有原因的。
So when you're on the show, it's easy to start to think maybe there's room in the annex for me too. Maybe I could also be a star. Obviously that was not going to happen. And so at a certain point I grew a beard, which is a daring thing to do in Hollywood where you're supposed to always look as young as possible. And that's when Mindy came in with her script and was like, hey, Aaron, could you read this restaurant scene? And I'm like, you want me to criticize your scene? And she's like, no, I want you to audition. And so she pulled me into the other room and there's Steve Carell, who's going to be directing this episode.
所以当你参与这部剧时，很容易开始觉得也许附楼里也有我的位置。也许我也能成为明星。显然那是不可能发生的。所以到了某个时候，我留了胡子，这在好莱坞是一件大胆的事，因为在那里你理应看起来尽可能年轻。就在那时，敏迪拿着她的剧本走过来，说：“嘿，亚伦，你能读一下这个餐厅场景吗？”我说：“你想让我评价你的场景？”她说：“不，我想让你试镜。”于是她把我拉进另一个房间，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在那里，他将执导这一集。
And I read the scene with him and I'm terrified. So I do a terrible job and yet they cast me. So the next week I'm on set and they send me to hair and makeup, the hair and makeup trailer. And when I walk in, they go, oh, it's our old waiter. So the beard, it turns out, actually got me the job. And then he started to trim the beard and kept trimming it. I was in there for like three hours and I got a little paranoid. Like, is this all because my beard was annoying Steve and he just cast me in an evil plot to get my beard to not look so scraggly?
我和他读了那个场景，我吓坏了。所以我表现得很糟糕，但他们还是选了我。所以下周我到了片场，他们把我送到化妆间。当我走进去时，他们说：“哦，是我们那个老服务员。”原来，胡子竟然让我得到了这份工作。然后他开始修剪胡子，不停地修。我在那儿待了大约三个小时，我变得有点多疑。心想，这一切是不是因为我的胡子让史蒂夫很烦，他只是把我安排进了一个邪恶的计划，好让我的胡子看起来不那么凌乱？
Of course that wasn't it. Okay, but I want to say, Aaron, I hear you because remember when Ryan went blonde? Yeah. That was because Mindy thought it would be funny for BJ to have to dye his hair blonde. So they created this whole plot. So why the character would do it? So maybe Mindy was like, that beard needs a trim and a tidy. Exactly.
当然不是那样。好吧，但我得说，亚伦，我懂你，因为还记得瑞安留金发的时候吗？是的。那是因为敏迪觉得让BJ染金发会很有趣。所以他们编造了整个情节。所以也许敏迪当时想的是，那胡子需要修剪整理一下。没错。
How can I do that? You know what? I'm going to write them into an episode. I also asked Aaron what it was like to shoot the scene. I wanted to know, like, did you get much direction? And he said they pretty much let him do his own thing, but that actually led to some problems. But I'll let him explain. Once I get on the actual set, I'm determined to do a good job for obvious reasons,
我该怎么做呢？你知道吗？我要把他们写进一集里。我还问了亚伦拍摄那个场景是什么感觉。我想知道，比如，你得到很多指导了吗？他说他们基本上让他自由发挥，但这实际上导致了一些问题。但我还是让他自己解释吧。一旦我到了真正的片场，出于显而易见的原因，我决心做好工作，
but also because there's a lot of hardworking actors out there who could have used this opportunity and I owe it to them to at least do a decent job. And also as a writer, I know how easy it is for an actor who has only a few lines to ruin his scene because they're nervous or because they think it's their star vehicle. So I'm going to do a good job. And Steve is directing it, but he assumes I know enough to do my own blocking. So I come up with my own, which is blocking is how you move around the set, right? And I come up with my own blocking and I did the dumbest thing, which is I started way back in the kitchen.
但也因为外面有很多努力工作的演员，他们本可以利用这个机会，我至少得对得起他们，表现得体。而且作为一名编剧，我知道对于一个只有几句台词的演员来说，因为紧张或者认为这是自己的成名作而毁掉场景是多么容易。所以我一定要做好。史蒂夫在执导，但他假设我知道如何自己走位。所以我自己设计了走位，也就是走位就是你在片场如何移动，对吧？我设计了自己的走位，但我做了最蠢的事，就是我从厨房的最深处开始。
I'm not even in the room. So all I can hear back there is Steve yell action and then I've got to walk in and I can't hear what's being said at the table and I got to find a way to land right on my cue. But this is my plan. I realized, OK, here's what I'm going to do. So my plan was I'm going to hide behind B camera. There's usually we had two cameras shooting simultaneously. And so if I'm behind B camera, I won't be in the shock as camera A isn't going to film camera B.
我甚至都不在房间里。所以我只能在后面听到史蒂夫大喊“开始”，然后我得走进去，我听不到桌边在说什么，我得想办法正好在我的提示点出现。但这就是我的计划。我意识到，好吧，我要这么做。所以我的计划是躲在B摄像机后面。通常我们有两台摄像机同时拍摄。所以如果我在B摄像机后面，我就不会出现在镜头里，因为A摄像机不会拍B摄像机。
That's not how the pros do it. But I, of course, couldn't be in front of camera B, but you've got to be behind. Anyway, when I come out, camera B has been moved to the further side of the restaurant. So now there's no way for me not to be on camera and to hear the scene. So I come up with this what I hope seems like a human behavior of circling the table slowly, trying to hear what's being said. And in this scene, you can see Steve looks over his shoulder like trying to find this weird lurking waiter. And this is proof that I was never an actual waiter because a real waiter knows how to show up at the table
专业人士不是这么做的。但我当然不能站在B摄像机前面，但你得站在后面。总之，当我出来时，B摄像机已经被移到了餐厅的另一边。所以现在我不可能不入镜，也不可能听不到场景内容。所以我提出了这个我希望看起来像人类行为的动作，慢慢绕着桌子走，试图听清他们在说什么。在这个场景里，你可以看到史蒂夫回头看，好像在试图找到这个奇怪的潜伏服务员。这证明了我从来不是一个真正的服务员，因为真正的服务员知道如何在最尴尬的时刻出现在桌边，
at the most awkward moment when somebody's heard terrible news and is about to start crying. But at the end of it all, I think it went fine and Steve was very kind and told me I did a good job. And that meant so much to me. I mean, what an opportunity to perform a script written by Mindy, directed by Steve, and to be on The Greatest Show ever. And now I'm on The Greatest Podcast ever. So thank you. Aw, thank you, Erin. Erin, that is so fun.
比如当有人听到可怕的消息正要哭出来的时候。但总的来说，我觉得还不错，史蒂夫非常友善，告诉我我做得很好。这对我意义重大。我是说，能表演敏迪写的剧本，由史蒂夫执导，并参与有史以来最伟大的剧集，这是多么好的机会。现在我还在有史以来最伟大的播客里。所以谢谢你们。噢，谢谢你，亚伦。亚伦，这太有趣了。
And we just love you. Also, Erin said for the record, he actually likes pickles, but not by the bowl. One of his lines that cracked me up because like he was saying, when you have only a few lines, it's really hard not to make them like the most important things you ever say. Yes. And he had this line when Michael says, could I get more pickles? And his first response is, of course. And that, of course, to me was so perfect.
我们真的很喜欢你。另外，亚伦说郑重声明，他其实喜欢酸黄瓜，但不是一整碗。他的一句台词让我笑喷了，因为就像他说的，当你只有几句台词时，真的很难不把它们说得像你这辈子说过最重要的事一样。是的。他有句台词，当迈克尔说：“能再给我点酸黄瓜吗？”他的第一反应是：“当然。”那个“当然”，对我来说太完美了。
Like anyone who's worked in food service knows that moment where you're like, absolutely, sure. I would love to do that. I would love to get you a bowl of pickles. Well, Erin is really starting to spiral. You know, she's got her face covered with her hair. She's making really heavy groaning sounds like that. Yeah. Michael delivers a famous line.
就像任何在餐饮业工作过的人都知道那一刻，你会觉得：“绝对没问题，当然。我很乐意这么做。我很乐意给你拿一碗酸黄瓜。”好吧，亚伦真的开始失控了。你知道，她用头发遮住了脸。她发出非常沉重的呻吟声，像那样。是的。迈克尔说了一句名台词。
It's from when Harry met Sally. Yes. He looks around the restaurant and says, I'll have what she's having. Mm-hmm. I went back and watched the scene after that. It's so brilliant. It makes me want to rewatch when Harry met Sally. Oh, I rewatched it recently.
那是出自《当哈利遇到莎莉》。是的。他环顾餐厅说：“我要点她点的那个。”嗯哼。在那之后我回去看了那个场景。太精彩了。这让我想重温《当哈利遇到莎莉》。噢，我最近重温了。
It's a flawless movie. It's terrific. Office ladies breaks down movies? Yeah. We have to do a series of rom-coms. Well, I also just rewatched Dirty Dancing. Yeah. I want to break down Dirty Dancing.
这是一部完美的电影。太棒了。《办公室女士》解析电影？是的。我们得做一系列浪漫喜剧。好吧，我也刚重温了《辣身舞》。是的。我想解析《辣身舞》。
Nobody puts baby in a corner. Come on. We need to watch it. We need to watch it. We need to watch it. Well, it's a very awkward car ride back to the office. Oh, is it? And lady, there was more in deleted scenes.
没人能把宝贝关在角落里。拜托。我们需要看它。我们需要看它。我们需要看它。好吧，回办公室的车程非常尴尬。噢，是吗？女士，删减片段里还有更多内容。
In the shooting draft, Michael is trying to console Aaron in the car. Right? He knows he's messed up. Mm-hmm. He says, you know, I think it's probably best to not say anything about this. And Aaron is just, like, stewing. He goes on to say, you know, take a beat. Calm down.
在拍摄草稿中，迈克尔在车里试图安慰亚伦。对吧？他知道他搞砸了。嗯哼。他说：“你知道，我觉得最好别提这件事。”而亚伦只是在生闷气。他接着说：“你知道，停顿一下。冷静点。”
Talk to him privately about it next week or a month, maybe never. It would probably make things awkward at work if you bring it up. Heck, you might even forget about it. And then, I don't know if you've noticed, Jenna, in the car scenes, there's a little patch on Michael's seatbelt that's frayed. It's right at his shoulder. And when I watched it, I did notice this sort of, like, fuzzy thing in a seatbelt. And I thought, why would they let that be in the shot?
下周或下个月私下跟他谈谈，也许永远别提。如果你提出来，可能会让工作变得尴尬。见鬼，你甚至可能忘了它。然后，我不知道你有没有注意到，珍娜，在车内场景中，迈克尔的安全带上有一小块磨损了。就在他的肩膀处。当我看到它时，我确实注意到了安全带上那种毛茸茸的东西。我想，他们为什么会让它出现在镜头里？
Why wouldn't they get him a seatbelt that wasn't damaged? Well, in deleted scenes, Michael says, sometimes I chew on my seatbelt when I'm upset. You can feel free to do that. Aaron does not respond. And then Michael shows her and starts to chew on his seatbelt. So they actually had to put chew marks on the seatbelt on purpose. Yes. Wow.
他们为什么不给他换一条没损坏的安全带？好吧，在删减片段里，迈克尔说：“我心烦的时候有时会咬我的安全带。你可以随意这样做。”亚伦没有回应。然后迈克尔向她展示并开始咬他的安全带。所以他们实际上是故意在安全带上弄出了咬痕。是的。哇。
And it's in deleted scenes. Michael, like, puts his seatbelt in his mouth. Anyway, that seatbelt was damaged on purpose. Well, when they get back to the office, Pam's milk is coming in. She's uncomfortable. She wants to pump. But her pump is missing. Yeah.
而且是在删减片段里。迈克尔把他的安全带放进嘴里。总之，那条安全带是故意弄坏的。好吧，当他们回到办公室时，帕姆的奶水下来了。她很不舒服。她想吸奶。但她的吸奶器不见了。是的。
Guess who has it? This was so crazy. I forgot about the scene. I forgot that Meredith took Pam's breast pump because it feels good. She likes how it feels. Oh, my gosh. Once again, Kate is fearless. Yeah.
猜猜谁拿了？这太疯狂了。我忘了这个场景。我忘了梅雷迪斯拿走了帕姆的吸奶器，因为它感觉很好。她喜欢那种感觉。噢，天哪。凯特再一次无所畏惧。是的。
So Pam is like, it's not sterile. She's very upset. And then Dwight is going to offer to hand express the milk. He's going to get it out for her. Yeah. She's like, no, thank you. No, thank you. When I watched the scene, all I could think about was the time when I was back on set
所以帕姆说：“那不消毒。”她非常生气。然后德怀特提出要帮她手挤奶。他要帮她挤出来。是的。她说：“不，谢谢。不，谢谢。”当我看到这个场景时，我能想到的只有我回到片场的那段时间，
after having Isabel and I was breastfeeding. And we were taking breaks so I could breastfeed. Kelly Cantley helped make that happen. And we were in the conference room. We were in there all day. And someone said, hey, what time is it? And I touched the side of my boobs. And I said, about 11 a.m.
在生下伊莎贝尔之后，我正在母乳喂养。我们休息时我可以喂奶。凯莉·坎特利帮忙促成了这件事。我们在会议室里。我们整天都在那儿。有人说：“嘿，几点了？”我摸了摸胸部一侧。我说：“大约上午11点。”
And then they were like, yeah, it's 10.59. Do you remember that? Yes. We all started cracking up and like doing this bit that I could tell time by. Yeah. We would be like, Angela, what time is it? We started testing you and you were very accurate. Because I had my whole pump schedule.
然后他们说：“是的，10点59分。”你记得吗？是的。我们都开始大笑，就像在做我能报时的这个梗。是的。我们会说：“安吉拉，几点了？”我们开始测试你，你非常准确。因为我有我自己的吸奶时间表。
Yeah. And your milk really does come in on a schedule. Yeah. Well, incidentally, you know, my mom told me that when I was born back in 1974, not as many women nursed their babies back then. But it was something that she was open to and she had done some research on. And she said when I was about two months old, her and my dad wanted to go out to dinner for the first time.
是的。而且你的奶水确实是按时间表下来的。是的。顺便说一句，你知道，我妈妈告诉我，当我1974年出生时，那时母乳喂养的女性没那么多。但这是她愿意尝试的事情，她做了一些研究。她说当我大约两个月大时，她和我爸爸想第一次出去吃晚饭。
She said they hired their very first babysitter. And in order to leave for that period of time for dinner, it took her an entire week of self-expressing using her hand, one bottle of milk. She kept it in the freezer so that the babysitter could defrost it and give it to me. Oh, my gosh. Yeah. The things our moms did for us. I know.
她说他们雇了他们的第一个保姆。为了离开那段时间去吃晚饭，她花了一整周的时间用手挤奶，挤了一瓶奶。她把它放在冰箱里，这样保姆就可以解冻并喂给我。噢，天哪。是的。我们的妈妈为我们做的事。我知道。
Oh, incidentally, I will say, Mindy also said that the idea that Meredith would steal Pam's breast pump was a pitch from Charlie Grandy. Andy is going to ask Erin how lunch went. And she is very cold to him. She then completely bites Oscar's head off. Oscar says, I think we're out of fax cover sheets. And she says, God, Oscar, will you keep your pants on? It's easy.
噢，顺便说一句，我要说，敏迪也说过，梅雷迪斯会偷帕姆吸奶器的想法是查理·格兰迪提出来的。安迪要问亚伦午餐吃得怎么样。她对他非常冷淡。然后她完全对奥斯卡发火了。奥斯卡说：“我想我们的传真封面用完了。”她说：“天哪，奥斯卡，你能把裤子穿好吗？”这很容易。
At nine minutes, 48 seconds, you guys, Oscar looks right to camera. Like, what the hell? Mm-hmm. But Oscar never looked right to camera. So this was really fun to spot. And I just loved him in that moment. I love that. Well, now we're going to go to the conference room because there is a secretary's day party
在9分48秒，伙计们，奥斯卡直接看向镜头。好像在说：“搞什么鬼？”嗯哼。但奥斯卡从不直接看向镜头。所以这真的很有趣。我喜欢那一刻的他。我喜欢那个。好吧，现在我们要去会议室，因为秘书节派对正在进行中，
underway. And Erin's honor, her face is on a cake. Yeah. And I think also it's on the plates. Oh, no way. I mean, it's a very elaborate party all thrown by Angela. Yes. Wait.
为了纪念亚伦，她的脸印在蛋糕上。是的。我想盘子上也有。噢，不会吧。我是说，这是一个非常精致的派对，全由安吉拉筹办。是的。等等。
Is she the head of the PPC again? That's what I'm wondering. Oh, wow. They slid that right in there. There was a couplet of dialogue between Ryan and Kelly in the scene. And as I watched it, I was like, that's just BJ and Mindy. Which one was it? They're talking about the Cookie Monster parody.
她又是PPC（派对策划委员会）的负责人了吗？我正想问这个。噢，哇。他们直接把这个塞进去了。在这个场景里，瑞安和凯莉之间有一段对话。当我看到它时，我想：“那简直就是BJ和敏迪。”是哪一段？他们在谈论芝麻街怪物的模仿。
Mm-hmm. And Kelly does her version of it. And Ryan goes, that's a little derivative. And Kelly says, but parody is always derivative. And Ryan says, it's not organic. Do you know what I mean? That just sounded like a conversation between the two of them. That could have been a conversation that we would hear them having on set.
嗯哼。凯莉做了她的版本。瑞安说：“那有点衍生。”凯莉说：“但模仿总是衍生的。”瑞安说：“那不自然。你懂我的意思吗？”那听起来就像他们两人之间的对话。那可能是我们在片场听到他们进行的对话。
Yes. 100%. So, you know, in this scene, Andy is going to put on his guitar. He's going to put on his harmonica. And he's going to sing Aaron a song called Secretary of Love. I had a question about the harmonica bit of it all. Uh-huh. He never straps on a harmonica.
是的。100%。所以，你知道，在这个场景里，安迪要戴上他的吉他。他要戴上他的口琴。他要给亚伦唱一首叫《爱的秘书》的歌。我对口琴那部分有个疑问。嗯哼。他从来没戴上口琴。
I think it was a little scheme to make sure the cake stayed up around his face. Well, it was in the script. I looked it up. It says Andy gets his guitar and one of those harmonicas attached to headgear. And Andy begins to sing an original song called Secretary of Love. It has a feel of Ricky Nelson's Travelin' Man. In the interview on Office Telly, Mindy mentioned that she wrote lyrics for the song Secretary of Love.
我觉得那是个小计谋，为了确保蛋糕能留在他的脸周围。好吧，剧本里有。我查过了。上面写着安迪拿了他的吉他，还有那种戴在头上的口琴。安迪开始唱一首原创歌曲叫《爱的秘书》。它有一种瑞奇·尼尔森的《旅行者》的感觉。在《办公室塔利》的采访中，敏迪提到她为《爱的秘书》这首歌写了歌词。
And they were in the table redraft. And Ed does play the harmonica. And they had intended for him to play it. Okay. Here are the lyrics. There's the secretary of labor, secretary of health, health and human resources just asked me on a date. Secretary of energy keeps on a winkin' at me,
它们在剧本朗读会上出现过。埃德确实吹了口琴。他们本来打算让他吹的。好吧。歌词如下。有劳工部长，卫生部长，卫生与公众服务部刚约我出去。能源部长一直对我眨眼，
but I can't keep my hands off of homeland security. But all the different secretaries that I've taken to my bed, there's only one secretary I can't get out of my head. The red haired secretary is the one I sing of. She's my Dunder Mifflin secretary, my secretary of love. Oh my gosh. I mean, in some ways it's good that he didn't sing it because Aaron already thinks he slept with everyone in the office.
但我无法把手从国土安全部身上移开。但在我带上床的所有不同秘书中，只有一个秘书是我无法忘怀的。红头发的秘书是我歌唱的对象。她是我的邓德·米夫林秘书，我的爱的秘书。噢，天哪。我是说，在某种程度上，他没唱出来是好事，因为亚伦已经认为他和办公室里的每个人都睡过了。
She's like, Phyllis Kelly? Pam? Jenna, in the shooting draft after Aaron says, who else did you sleep with, huh? Phyllis Kelly, Pam? This was the direction for us in the shooting draft. Angela hides her face in her hands. Phyllis Kelly and Pam Adlib. Oh God, no. Are you kidding me? Barf me to death. Aaron then lets out a weird sound from deep within her chest. Well, I know we talked about this moment
她说：“菲利斯？凯莉？帕姆？”珍娜，在拍摄草稿中，在亚伦说：“你还和谁睡过，嗯？菲利斯？凯莉？帕姆？”这是拍摄草稿中给我们的指导。安吉拉把脸埋在手里。菲利斯、凯莉和帕姆即兴表演。“噢，天哪，不。你在开玩笑吗？恶心死我了。”亚伦随后从胸腔深处发出一种奇怪的声音。好吧，我知道我们谈论过这一刻，
when Aaron hits Andy in the face with the cake during our interview with Ellie, but I also found a little tidbit from Mindy on Office Tally about it. She said that the cake was really dense and that the first time Ellie threw it at Ed, it made a really loud sound. It sounded like whack. That's why we reacted like that.
当亚伦在采访艾莉时用蛋糕砸安迪的脸，但我也在《办公室塔利》上发现了敏迪关于这件事的一点花絮。她说蛋糕真的很扎实，艾莉第一次把它扔向埃德时，发出了很大的声音。听起来像“啪”。这就是为什么我们会有那样的反应。
We had a fan question from Mary Kay in Portland, Oregon. I think the real question we all want to know the answer to is how good was that cake because it looks delicious. I really ate that cake. Me too. It was delicious. It was so good. Mary, good call. It was great. Well, people are going to start trying to make Aaron feel better. Kevin tries to console her, hit on her, and while that is happening,
我们有一个来自俄勒冈州波特兰市玛丽·凯的粉丝提问。我想我们都想知道的真正问题是那个蛋糕有多好吃，因为它看起来很美味。我真的吃了那个蛋糕。我也是。它很美味。太好吃了。玛丽，问得好。它很棒。好吧，人们开始试图让亚伦感觉好点。凯文试图安慰她，勾引她，就在这时，
Gabe overhears Pam doing an impression of Kevin. I want to point out when Jim laughs, that was John's laugh. Yeah. That is exactly how he starts to laugh. That's a good call. It's true. Gabe is going to suspend them. He suspends Pam, he suspends Jim, and then he even is going to suspend Dwight for slow clapping the suspension.
盖博无意中听到帕姆在模仿凯文。我想指出当吉姆笑的时候，那是约翰的笑声。是的。那就是他开始笑的方式。问得好。是真的。盖博要停职他们。他让帕姆停职，让吉姆停职，然后他甚至要让德怀特停职，因为他为停职缓慢鼓掌。
Kevin is so happy. He says C is for suspension. Oh, Kevin. Kevin. Meanwhile, in Michael's office, Andy has a great line where he's like, I don't understand how my past engagement came up in your restaurant talk. Yeah. It's secretary's day. How did this come up? But I'm with Michael.
凯文太高兴了。他说：“C代表停职。”噢，凯文。凯文。与此同时，在迈克尔的办公室里，安迪有一句很棒的台词，他说：“我不明白我过去的订婚是怎么在你们的餐厅谈话中提出来的。”是的。今天是秘书节。这怎么会提出来？但我站在迈克尔这边。
Like, why did you keep this a secret from her? How is Michael supposed to know that she doesn't know? This is not, I think, an example of Michael revealing a secret. Right. Like he has been known to do in the past. Right. Exactly. Michael didn't even know this was an off-topic subject. Yeah. Well, Andy is now going to have a very agonizing talking head.
就像，你为什么要对她隐瞒这件事？迈克尔怎么会知道她不知道？我认为这不是迈克尔泄露秘密的例子。对吧。就像他过去常做的那样。对吧。没错。迈克尔甚至不知道这是一个禁忌话题。是的。好吧，安迪现在要进行一次非常痛苦的独白。
He's like, who cares? It'll blow over. Maybe I should have told her. Everybody does stupid things. He's like all over the map. Well, it's actually like a series of talking heads sort of intercut into one talking head, which I'm not sure we've ever seen before. Yeah. I just wanted to point out that at the top of the episode,
他说：“谁在乎呢？这会过去的。也许我应该告诉她。每个人都会做蠢事。”他就像完全乱了方寸。好吧，这实际上是一系列独白，剪辑成了一个独白，我不确定我们以前是否见过。是的。我只是想指出在这一集的开头，
at one minute, 20 seconds, Andy says that it's not only secretary's day, but it's also he and Aaron's three-week anniversary. And I just want to put this out there. I think maybe if you've just been dating someone for three weeks and they go to such effort to celebrate you on secretary's day, maybe you can say, hey, why didn't you tell me about this previous relationship that really upset me?
在1分20秒，安迪说这不仅是秘书节，也是他和亚伦的三周纪念日。我只想说出来。我觉得也许如果你刚和某人约会三周，而他们如此努力地在秘书节庆祝你，也许你可以说：“嘿，你为什么不告诉我这段让我非常难过的过去的关系？”
It's only been three weeks, you guys. I think there's still some discovery. Am I wrong? Well, it's interesting you asked this question because we got mail from both Liza A. in North Carolina and Paul W. in Chicago asking, if you were Andy, would you have told Aaron that you were once engaged or would you have waited? And do you agree with Aaron's decision
伙计们，才三周。我觉得还有一些发现的过程。我错了吗？好吧，你问这个问题很有趣，因为我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州的丽莎·A和芝加哥的保罗·W的邮件，问：“如果你是安迪，你会告诉亚伦你曾经订过婚吗，还是会等一等？”你同意亚伦的决定吗
to break up with him because of this? Well, listen, I think it would have been a big flipping conversation. I would have been upset. But at three weeks, I might have understood that maybe he was waiting for the right moment to tell me. I have to say I 100% understand Aaron's reaction. It's not just that he didn't tell her that he's been engaged before, but this is a co-worker that she sees every day.
因为这个和他分手？好吧，听着，我觉得那会是一场巨大的谈话。我会很生气。但在三周的时候，我可能会理解也许他在等合适的时机告诉我。我必须说我100%理解亚伦的反应。不仅仅是他没告诉她他以前订过婚，而且这是一个她每天都能见到的同事。
So I think that that makes it different. I think that's something that you need to say right away. I agree. If you've just started dating someone, maybe around, I don't know, around this time, three weeks a month, you might say, oh, I was engaged before. Here's all my business because we've lasted three weeks.
所以我认为这让情况变得不同。我认为这是你需要立刻说出来的事情。我同意。如果你刚开始和某人约会，也许在，我不知道，大约这个时候，三周一个月，你可能会说：“噢，我以前订过婚。这是我的所有私事，因为我们已经持续三周了。”
Maybe we're going to make a real go of it. Here's everything. Right, but not if the situation is like, hey, you should know I actually used to be engaged to my roommate. Yeah. You know, like that's like that. Like, oh, I used to be engaged to this person right next to you. Right.
也许我们要认真对待这段关系。这是所有的一切。对，但如果情况是这样：“嘿，你应该知道我其实曾经和我室友订过婚。”是的。你知道，就像那样。就像：“噢，我曾经和你旁边的那个人订过婚。”对。
And everyone in this room knows. Yes. But you. That's the difference. Yeah, I see that. But do you think it's breakup worthy? Yes. Okay.
而且这个房间里的每个人都知道。是的。除了你。这就是区别。是的，我明白了。但你认为这值得分手吗？是的。好吧。
I would feel very embarrassed. Embarrassed. And humiliated and distrustful. Yeah. Of like, I don't know. It makes me think twice about the person, frankly. I get that. Yeah.
我会感到非常尴尬。尴尬。而且羞辱和不信任。是的。就像，我不知道。坦率地说，这让我对这个人三思而后行。我明白了。是的。
It's because they're in the same office. Mm-hmm. Well, now Angela is going to try to console Erin as best as she can. She's like, hey, Erin, and I love this line. Erin's like, you want to talk to me? Come to my desk. Yeah. She's ready to throw down.
这是因为他们在同一个办公室。嗯哼。好吧，现在安吉拉要尽她所能安慰艾琳。她说：“嘿，艾琳。”我喜欢这句台词。艾琳说：“你想跟我谈谈？到我桌子这儿来。”是的。她准备好要打架了。
They have this hilarious dialogue. We talked about it with Ellie, where they go back and forth about wanting to throw up just thinking about it. Yeah. And then at the end of the scene, the camera pulls back and Toby is standing there. He can't seem to work the fax machine. Suddenly, everybody has to fax things today and it's not working well. Yeah.
他们有这段搞笑的对话。我们和艾莉谈过，他们来回争论想到这件事就想吐。是的。然后在场景结束时，摄像机拉远，托比站在那里。他似乎无法操作传真机。突然，每个人今天都要传真东西，而且效果不好。是的。
Everyone's real busy at reception. Mindy said that that reveal of Toby having been there for this whole exchange was Steve's idea. It was really funny. Well, now Pam is going to try to console Erin. And I thought she was so, like, eloquent in this moment. I know. We talked about this with Ellie, too. It doesn't work again.
每个人在前台都很忙。敏迪说托比一直在这场交流中是史蒂夫的主意。这真的很有趣。好吧，现在帕姆要试图安慰艾琳。我觉得她在这一刻非常、非常雄辩。我知道。我们也和艾莉谈过这个。它又坏了。
It's too bad. But then Pam is going to walk over and give Jim a kiss. And we haven't kind of seen any, like, kissy-kiss between Jim and Pam in a while. So I thought this was a really nice kind of romantic moment. Kind of took us back. Yeah. Gabe is going to get some news now. At 15 minutes and 48 seconds, he is standing in a hallway.
太可惜了。但随后帕姆走过去给了吉姆一个吻。我们已经有一段时间没看到吉姆和帕姆之间那种亲吻了。所以我认为这是一个非常好的浪漫时刻。有点把我们带回去了。是的。盖博现在要得到一些消息。在15分48秒，他站在走廊里。
He's talking to corporate. Randy told me that this was filmed in the stairway directly opposite the door to his office in the writer's area. He said that Steve Carell chose the stairwell because it was rarely used. And Steve thought that it would be good to see Gabe in a setting that was more unfamiliar to viewers. I love how so much thought goes into every moment. Little moment. Yeah. When I think of the stairwell, I always think of Dwight.
他在和总部通话。兰迪告诉我这是在编剧区他办公室门对面的楼梯间拍摄的。他说史蒂夫·卡瑞尔选择了楼梯间，因为它很少被使用。史蒂夫认为在观众更不熟悉的场景中看到盖博会很好。我喜欢每一个时刻都投入了这么多思考。小小的时刻。是的。当我想到楼梯间时，我总是想到德怀特。
Pumping himself up. Yeah. Exactly. Or moaning and wailing. Yes. Well, on this phone call, Gabe is going to learn that he actually cannot reprimand or suspend anyone. And then Toby is going to call Pam and tell her the same thing. He also says to her, I found out some of the other things they're doing out there.
给自己打气。是的。没错。或者呻吟和哀号。是的。好吧，在这个电话里，盖博将得知他实际上不能训斥或停职任何人。然后托比会给帕姆打电话告诉她同样的事情。他还对她说：“我发现了一些他们在外面做的其他事情。”
And she hangs up on it. Yeah. I know. She's like, I got all the information I need. She passes a note to Jim and now they know exactly what they're going to do. Yeah. They're going to take their suspension. Yeah.
然后她挂断了电话。是的。我知道。她说：“我已经得到了我需要的所有信息。”她给吉姆传了一张纸条，现在他们确切地知道他们要做什么了。是的。他们要接受停职。是的。
Paid. They're going to go home and think about their behavior. Yeah. Well, Dwight is going to apologize, but Gabe is running after Pam and Jim. He does not want them to leave because now he's got egg on his face. When he comes back in the bullpen, Oscar's like, is it me or did they just get a paid day off? Mm-hmm. To which Gabe now tries to do his Cookie Monster impression.
带薪的。他们要回家思考他们的行为。是的。好吧，德怀特要道歉，但盖博在追赶帕姆和吉姆。他不想让他们离开，因为现在他丢脸了。当他回到办公室时，奥斯卡说：“是我还是他们刚刚得到了带薪休假？”嗯哼。对此，盖博现在试图模仿芝麻街怪物。
Right. This leads us to what I'm calling Jedi Kevin. All right. At 18 minutes, 23 seconds, Kevin is at his desk when Gabe starts his Cookie Monster impression. And then at 18 minutes, 28 seconds, Kevin is now standing at Angela's desk as he starts doing his impression of Gabe. And then at 18 minutes, 37 seconds, Kevin is now standing next to Gabe by front reception as he continues his impression.
对。这引出了我称之为“绝地凯文”的部分。好吧。在18分23秒，凯文在他的桌子旁，盖博开始模仿芝麻街怪物。然后在18分28秒，凯文现在站在安吉拉的桌子旁，开始模仿盖博。然后在18分37秒，凯文现在站在前台盖博旁边，继续他的模仿。
Those are amazing catches. He's just what? He's teleporting. Yes. Around. Second by second. He's moving around. Well, I don't know what was going on while we were shooting the scene.
那些是惊人的捕捉。他只是什么？他在瞬间移动。是的。到处。一秒接一秒。他在四处走动。好吧，我不知道我们在拍摄那个场景时发生了什么。
I went to the script because a lot of the impressions that everyone starts doing of Gabe were not in the script. Like Dwight's impression of Gabe was not in the script, so I don't know what happened. It wasn't there. Were they just throwing out? Like, I think this scene changed a lot, and that's why maybe Kevin is all over the room. Yes. I made note of this as well.
我查了剧本，因为每个人开始模仿盖博的很多模仿都不在剧本里。比如德怀特模仿盖博就不在剧本里，所以我不知道发生了什么。它不在那儿。他们只是在即兴发挥吗？就像，我觉得这个场景变了很多，这就是为什么凯文可能在房间里到处都是。是的。我也注意到了这一点。
I think we just started riffing, and some of the reactions you see are so honest. I want to show you at 18 minutes, 43 seconds, Creed and I are just hysterically laughing. We're not in character at all. Look at the screen grab. Oh yeah, for sure. I love that. I'll put it in stories. Well, this whole plot of the dubbing of the voice on the characters is going to end with
我觉得我们只是开始即兴发挥，你看到的一些反应非常真实。我想在18分43秒给你看，克里德和我只是歇斯底里地大笑。我们根本没在角色里。看截图。噢，是的，当然。我喜欢那个。我会把它发到故事里。好吧，这个给角色配音的情节将以
Kevin playing a video of Oscar as the Count, but nobody is getting it. Except Michael. Michael thinks he nailed it. And at the very end of the episode, Michael says, good work, Cookie Monster. It's kind of sweet. But then of course, the episode also ends with that wonderful scene on the bench with Michael there, and we talked about it with Ellie, where Michael is being really sweet with her. He is being the father she never had.
凯文播放奥斯卡作为伯爵的视频结束，但没人明白。除了迈克尔。迈克尔认为他做到了。在这一集的最后，迈克尔说：“干得好，芝麻街怪物。”这有点甜。但当然，这一集也以长椅上那个精彩的场景结束，迈克尔在那里，我们和艾莉谈过，迈克尔对她非常温柔。他正在扮演她从未有过的父亲。
And Andy's kind of watching from his car, from across the street. Yeah. Andy says at least someone made her happy on Secretary's Day. Did you notice that it was like nighttime in Andy's car, but it's daytime on the bench? Did you notice that? Was it just me? I didn't notice that. I'll have to go back and look.
安迪在街对面的车里看着。是的。安迪说至少有人在秘书节让她开心了。你注意到安迪车里是晚上，但长椅上是白天吗？你注意到了吗？是我一个人吗？我没注意到。我得回去看看。
Yeah. Guys, that's Secretary's Day. This Andy-Aaron breakup is going to start a whole new series of storylines. We're going to see more of Gabe, and I'm very excited for that, because one of the things I loved about this episode was just seeing Zach Woods do his thing. He's so flippin' funny. So we'll see you next week. We've got body language.
是的。伙计们，这就是秘书节。安迪和亚伦的分手将开启一系列全新的故事情节。我们将看到更多盖博，我对此非常兴奋，因为我喜欢这一集的一点就是看到扎克·伍兹做他自己的事。他太搞笑了。所以我们下周见。我们有肢体语言。
Body language, and I've got a Pam hair catch, but you're going to have to wait for it. Oh. Well, stay tuned for that. We'd love to say thank you to Aaron Sher for sitting in those audio clips. Aaron, you're the best, and Randy Cordray for giving us those behind-the-scenes details. We'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
肢体语言，我还有一个帕姆头发的捕捉，但你得等一等。噢。好吧，敬请期待。我们要感谢亚伦·谢尔参与这些音频片段。亚伦，你是最棒的，还有兰迪·科德雷给我们提供那些幕后细节。我们下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。
Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是安斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。如需无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码：OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。